So I've been thinking this week about
doing this one of them once a month on a
continuing basis,
so thank you.
So I think if I do that,
I think it will be here,
although it's harder to rent this
theater during the academic year,
but if it isn't here it will be
somewhere else and I'd like to continue
doing this.
I'm learning a lot from doing it and,
and uh,
once a month would really be good
because then I could really do the
background work and,
and uh,
and I could probably do that for a
couple of years because obviously this
is going very quickly,
but that's okay.
You know,
I mean,
it shouldn't go any faster than it can
go and that's how it,
that's how it seems to me anyways.
So,
uh,
this has been,
this has been a very steep learning
curve for me with regards to these
stories because I didn't understand them
very well and I've got better at using
the resources on line to help me do my
background investigation.
I have a lot of books and some of you
may have noticed that I'm online.
I posted a conversation I had with
Jonathan Otto and his and his brother
Matthew.
Um,
I hope it's matthew.
I re names escape me so badly,
but I believe that's right.
He just finished a book on the,
on the Bible and so I've been doing a
lot of thinking and talking about these
stories,
trying to understand what they're about.
And,
and then there's all these commentaries,
there's a great site,
I think it's called Bible hub that has
every single verse of the Bible is
listed there.
And then with each verse there are like
they've aggregated 10 commentaries from
about 10 commentaries from over the last
400 years.
And so there's like a dense page on
every line and that's one of the things
that's really interesting about this
book too,
is that it's,
it's aggregated so much commentary that
it's,
that it's,
it's much bigger than it looks.
The book is much bigger than it looks.
And so it's been very interesting to
become familiar with those two.
And the fact that this site is set up
with all the commentary split up by
versus means you can rapidly compare the
commentaries and get a sense of,
you know,
how people have interpreted this over
while at least several hundred years,
but of course much longer than that
because of the people who wrote the
commentaries were of course reading
things that were older than that.
So that's been very,
very interesting.
Um,
so last week we talked about a couple of
things.
We talked about how you might understand
the idea of a divine encounter.
And then we also paralleled that with
the idea that God disappears in the Old
Testament.
He,
he bows out as the stories progress.
And that seems to be a,
an emergent property.
The sequencing of the stories,
right?
Because all the books were written by
independent people are different people
and then they were aggregated by other
people.
And so the narrative continuity,
is it some kind of emergent property
that's,
that's a consequence of this interaction
between people,
readers and writers over centuries.
And it's strange that given that there
are also multiple coherent narratives
that united,
you know,
it's really,
it's really not that easy to understand
that,
but it does at least seem to be the
case.
And so,
and the third thing we talked about was
that as God bows out,
so to speak,
the,
the individual personality seems of the,
of the characters that are involved,
the human characters that are involved
seems to become more and more developed.
And it isn't exactly clear what that,
I mean,
what it means is that God steps away and
man steps forward.
That's what it means.
But why it's arranged like that or they
or they say ultimate significance of
that is by no means clear.
And so.
So Abraham,
who we're going to concentrate on today
is quite a well developed character.
And I would say there are two,
there are multiple endings and
beginnings in the biblical stories.
The most important ending,
I suppose,
is the ending of the of the garden of
Paradise and and the the disenchantment
of the world and the and the sending
forth of Adam and eve into history,
right into the future,
into a,
into a mode of being that has a future
as part of it and that has history as
part of it and that has the necessity of
sacrifice and toil as part of it.
That's obviously crucial and then
that's.
That is replayed with the story of Noah
because everything is destroyed and then
the world is created a new and then
sacrifices have to be made in order for
the world to begin.
And then you see the same thing happen
again after the Noah story and the Tower
of Babel.
Because history,
as we really understand history seems to
start with Abraham because the stories
of Abraham sound like historical stories
and you know,
scholars debate about the historical
accuracy of the Bible.
And I suppose there's.
There's no way of determining once and
for all the degree to which you might
regard the accounts as equivalent to
modern empirical history.
But this is a psychological
interpretation of the biblical stories,
not a historical interpretation,
and it certainly does seem to be the
case that from a psychological
perspective,
we enter something like the domain of
the modern conceptualization,
relatively modern conceptualization of
history with Abraham beyond the accounts
of divine commands that Abraham carries
out.
This is from Friedman,
man,
I mentioned in the last lecture who
wrote the disappearance of God in a
variety of other books that are well
worth reading.
The narrative also includes a variety of
stories in which Abraham acts on his own
initiative.
He divides land with his nephew lot.
He battles kings,
he takes concubines,
he argues with his wife Sarah.
On two occasions he tells kings that
Sarah is his sister out of fear,
that they will kill him to get his wife.
He arranges his son's marriage in the
place of the single story of Noah's
drunkenness.
There are,
in the case of Abraham,
the stories of a man's life.
And one of the things I was really
struck by reading this in depth and
reading the commentary is how much like
a story about a person it is,
you know,
Abraham isn't a divine figure in,
in any,
in any archetipal sense.
Precisely.
I mean he has architectural elements
because he's also obviously the founder
of a nation.
But fundamentally he's a human being
and,
and he makes,
he has the adventures and he makes the
mistakes of a human being.
And that's,
it's the mistake part that really struck
me.
You know,
because it,
it,
it.
I was talking with a friend of mine this
week,
Norman Doidge,
whose a very remarkable person in many
ways and he was taking me to task.
He was reading my book,
which I'm going to publish,
which will be out in January.
And in the book are in one section.
I contrasted the god of the Old
Testament with the god of the New
Testament and made the case sort of
based on North Road fries ideas that the
god of the Old Testament was really
harsh and judgmental,
you know?
And that the god of the New Testament
was more merciful and you know,
at least to some degree,
more sweetness and light.
And Norman took me to task about that,
saying that that was a,
an overly christianized interpretation,
which would make sense because I derived
it in part from northrop Frye.
And I really have come to understand
that more that,
that he's right because that he's right
about that because the god in the Old
Testament is actually far more merciful
than he's generally made out to be.
And you really see this with a.
it's good news for fundamentally,
if you regard the representation of God
as somehow key to the description of
being itself.
I mean,
Abraham makes a lot of mistakes,
you know,
serious mistakes.
And,
and yet he has a life and he's,
and he's blessed by God despite the fact
that he's pretty deeply flawed and
engages in deceptive practice.
I mean,
he's a good man,
but he's not a perfect man by any
stretch of the imagination and,
and things work out really well for him.
And he's the founder of a nation and all
of that.
And that's good news for everyone
because perfect people are very,
very hard to find.
And if the,
the,
the only pathway to having a rich and
meaningful life was through perfection,
then we would all be in deep trouble.
And so that's very satisfying to read
that.
And the other,
the other thing that I've been struck by
is that,
you know,
Abraham,
and I think this is actually absolutely
key to the interpretation of the story.
Abraham goes out and does things.
That's the thing.
And so one of the things that I've
noticed in my life is that nothing I've
ever done was wasted.
And by done,
I mean put my heart and soul into it,
you know,
like,
like attempted with,
with all of my effort that always
worked.
Now it didn't always work the way I
expected it to work.
That's a whole different issue.
But the payoff from it was always
positive.
I always something always something of
value always accrued to me when I made
the sacrifices necessary to do
worthwhile.
And so I think part of the message in
this story of a,
the abrahamic stories is go do
something.
And,
and I've,
I've,
I've thought about this in a variety of
ways outside of the interpretation of
this story because I have this program
some of you might be familiar with which
is called future authoring program and
it's designed to help people make a plan
for three to five years into the future.
You know?
And so what you do is you,
you answer some questions,
it's a writing program.
You answered some questions about how
you would like your life to be,
what you would like your character to be
three to five years down the road if you
were taking care of yourself.
Like you are taking care of someone that
you actually cared about.
So you kind of have to split yourself
into two people and treat yourself like
you,
like someone you have respect for and
that you want the best.
For now it's not easy because people
don't necessarily have respect for
themselves and they don't necessarily
want what's the best for themselves
because they have a lot of self contempt
and a lot of self hatred and a lot of
guilt and a lot of existential angst.
And and a lot of self consciousness and
all of that,
and so people don't necessarily take
care of themselves very well and I think
it's.
I think it's.
I think you have an obligation.
It's one of the highest moral
obligations to treat yourself as if
you're a creature of value and that is
in some sense it's in some sense that's
independent of your actions and you
might think about that metaphorically as
a recognition of your divine worth in
the biblical sense,
regardless of your,
of your sins,
so to speak.
And I think that's,
that's,
that's powerful language as far as I'm
concerned.
Once you understand it anyways with the
self authoring program in the future
authoring program,
you,
you ask you answer questions about what,
what,
how you would like your friendships to
be conducted because it's useful to
surround yourself with people who are
trying to move forward and more
importantly,
who are happy when you move forward and
not happy when you move back backwards.
Not when you fall.
That isn't what I mean,
but when you're doing self destructive
things,
your friends shouldn't be there to cheer
you on and because then they're really
not acting like friends.
Obviously,
you know,
I know it's obvious,
but it still happens all the time and
people allow it to happen.
It's not a good idea.
And now how would you like to sort your
family out,
and I was thinking about this this week
too because I was thinking about Noah's
Ark and there was a phrase in that story
that I didn't understand,
which was that noah was perfect in his
generations.
I thought,
I don't know what that means and you
know when you're,
when you're going through a book like
the Bible,
if you don't understand a phrase that
actually means you've missed something,
it doesn't mean that that's just not.
You know,
that's not Germane to the story.
It means you're stupid.
You didn't get it,
man.
You didn't get it.
You didn't understand it.
And so the idea that Noah was perfect in
his generations and that's why he could
build an arc that would sustain him and
him and and humanity itself through the
flood.
It meant that he not only did he walk
with God,
which is something that we talked about
in the context of the sermon on the
mount,
but the established proper relationships
with his family,
with his children.
And so what that meant was that his,
not only was he well integrated as a
person,
but his level of integration had reached
the point where it's stretched out
beyond him and encompassed his family.
And so it was noah and the family that
was in the arc.
And I can tell you,
and I really understood this this year
because I had a very tumultuous year or
you could think about it from a personal
perspective.
I could think about it as a year that
had no shortage of floods.
And My.
And part of the reason that I was able
to get through it.
I also had terrible health problems.
And one of the reasons I was able to get
through it was because my family really
came together around me,
my kids,
my wife,
my parents and my friends as well,
and particularly a certain group of
friends and that's partly all of that
came together in my mind this week and I
thought,
oh,
that's what it means to be perfect in
his generations meant that he hadn't
just straightened himself out.
He'd also straightened out his
relationships with his family and I can
tell you that when crisis strikes you,
which it will,
it will.
The flood will come,
right?
That's why the apocalypse has always
upon us.
The flood will definitely come into your
life and to the degree that you've
organized yourself psychologically and
also healed the relationships between
you and your family.
That could be the critical element that
determines whether you live or die when
a crisis comes or or whether it's
someone in your family lives or dies.
And so the idea of the arc containing
the man who's who walks with God and
whose generations are perfect and that
that's what sustains humanity through
the crisis.
It's like you couldn't be more
psychologically accurate than that.
You know,
the other thing I was thinking about
this week I,
I was thinking about another line in the
new testament.
I think it's from the sermon on the
mount,
but I'm not absolutely sure.
Christ compares the Kingdom of Heaven to
a mustard seed and so I was thinking
about a mustard seed is a very tiny seed
and it grows into quite a spectacular
complex plant and I was thinking about
how you should operate in the world in
order to make it a better place,
assuming that that's what you should be
doing and that is what you should be
doing and there there's lots in the
world to fix everything that bothers you
about the world and about yourself
should be fixed and you can do that.
And my dawning realization,
I have a friend,
he lives in Montreal.
His name is James.
Simon is a great painter and he's taught
me a lot of things,
helped.
He's helped me design my house and
beautify it and I bought some paintings
from him a couple of years ago and he
did this series of paintings where he
went around North America and stood in
different places and then he painted the
view from here down and so it's his feet
planted in different places on roads in
the desert,
on the ocean.
I have one actually hanging over my
toilet,
which is him standing at a urinal.
I'm now.
Well,
you know,
he was trying to make a point and the
point was that wherever you are,
it's worth paying attention and that's
because you know,
so all these places that he visited,
he looked exactly
where he was standing by the side of the
road in the desert side of mundane in
some sense.
But then maybe he put 40 hours into that
painting.
You know,
when it's very,
very realistic painting with really good
light.
And what he's telling you as a painter
is everything is worth paying attention
to an infinite amount,
but you don't have enough time.
And so the artists does that for you.
Right?
The artist looks and locks and locks and
locks and locks and then gives you that
vision and so then you can look at the
painting and it reminds you that right
where you are is there's every
everything that there is is right where
you are and that's a hard thing to
realize,
but it's actually true.
And so I've been telling people online
in various ways and the lectures that
they should start fixing up the world by
cleaning up the room.
And I wanted to just elaborate on that a
little bit before I get back to the
lecture itself.
So I'd say it's become this Internet
weird Internet meme,
you know,
and,
and it's a joke and good.
It's a jewel.
I really happy about the fact that so
much of this has got the leaving of
humor and it's really important because
that's what stops things from
degenerating into,
into conflict humor.
And I was thinking about this idea of
cleaning up your room in relationship to
the mustard seed idea.
And you see the thing about cleaning up
your room.
This is also something I learned from
Carl young and his studies on alchemy
because for young,
when the alchemist was attempting to
make the philosopher's stone,
he was not only engaged in the
transformation of the material world,
but he was engaged in a process of self
transformation that occurred at the same
time as the as the chemical trap,
as the chemical transformation,
so it was a psychological work in some
sense.
Let's say you want to sort out your room
and beautified because the beauty is
also important and let's say that all
you have is just a little room like
you're not rich.
You're poor and you don't have any
power.
That's another thing,
but you've got your damn room and you've
got this space right in front of you.
You know that that's a part of the
cosmos that you can come to grips with
and you might think,
well,
what's there in front of you right in
front of you?
And the answer to that is it depends on
how open your eyes are.
That's the proper answer because you
could say,
w William Blake said this,
for example,
eldest Huxley made comments that were
very similar that in a transcendent
state,
you can see infinity in the finite and
you might say,
well,
you can say,
and you can see infinity in what you
have within your grasp.
If you look and you could save,
maybe that's the case with your room,
and so you want to clean up your room.
Well,
okay,
how do you do that?
Exactly?
Well,
a room,
his room is a place to sleep and so if
you set your room up properly,
then you figure out how to sleep and
when you should sleep and how you should
sleep,
and then you figure out when you should
wake up and then you figure out,
well,
what clothes you should wear because
they have to be arranged properly in
your dresser,
and then you have to have some place to
put your clothes and you're going to
have some clothes.
You have to figure out what you're going
to wear those clothes to do.
Right?
And then that means you have to figure
out what you're going to do and then
your room has to serve that purpose
because otherwise it isn't set up
properly and if it doesn't set up,
if it doesn't serve your purposes,
you will be unhappy and not happy in the
room because the way that we perceive
the world is as a place to move from
point a to point B in,
and then if the place that we're in
facilitates that movement,
then we're happy to be there.
And if the place that we're in serves as
an obstacle to that movement,
then we're unhappy to be there.
And so what it means to set up your room
is that you have to have somewhere to go
that's worthwhile.
Or you can set up your room and your
room has to be set up to facilitate
that.
And then the next thing is,
well maybe you have to make it
beautiful,
but that's not easy,
right?
That means you have to have some taste
and that doesn't mean you have to have
money.
It doesn't because you can be garish
with money and you can be tasteful with
nothing.
All you need is taste and taste,
beats money when it comes to beautifying
things,
that money is trivial because it's not.
The taste is crucial and people who are
very artistically oriented can make
beautiful things out of virtually
nothing and not only that,
the literature suggests that if you're
going to make beautiful things,
putting real constraints on,
on what you allow yourself to do,
facilitates creativity instead of
interfering with it.
Because let's say you have to make
something out of nothing,
right?
Which I suppose would be a Godly Act,
You have to make something out of
nothing.
You have to be creative in order to do
that,
and so then to beautify your room means
that you also have to develop your
capacity to be creative and so then you
can make your room shine,
but then what will happen is that if
your family isn't together,
they will interfere with that.
You will interfere with that because you
won't have the discipline to do it
properly,
but then when you start building this,
this,
this little microcosm of perfection with
what you have at hand and it'll evoke
all the pathologies of everyone in your
household.
The wonder what the hell you're up to in
there and they won't necessarily be
happy because if you're.
If they're in a lowly place,
let's say,
and so are you and you're trying to move
out of that than the higher you move out
of that,
the more the place they're in looks bad
and you might say,
well,
what they should do is celebrate your
victory over chaos and evil,
but that isn't what will happen.
What will happen instead is that they
will attempt to pull you back down.
They'll attempt to,
and obviously all families don't do
that,
but,
but all families do that to some degree
and some families do almost nothing but
that.
And so what that means is that if you're
going to organize your room,
then you're going to have to confront
the devils in your house.
And that's often.
That's often a terrifying thing because
some of those devils have have lineages
that go back many,
many,
many generations and God only knows what
you have to struggle with in order to
overcome that and so and so to sort
yourself out into fix up your room is a
nontrivial matter.
You know,
and you can do that.
You'll learn by doing that and then
maybe you'll learn enough by doing that
so that you can fix up your family a
little bit and then having done that,
you'll have enough character so that
when you to operate in the world at your
job or maybe in the broader social
spheres,
that you will be a force for good
instead of harm because you'll have
learned some humility by noting just how
difficult it was to put your damn room
together well and yourself for that
matter.
And so you'll proceed cautiously with
your eyes open towards the good and so
well.
Those are some of the things I've been
thinking about this week and they're
Germane,
Germane to what we're going to discuss
tonight.
Because what happens at the beginning of
the abrahamic stories is basically God
comes to Abraham and just says,
go get going,
man,
do something,
get going.
And you might think,
well,
where should I go?
And God,
God is somewhat vague about that in
where he sends Abraham.
It's a real fixer upper man.
It's like there's starvation narrow,
and there's tyranny and there's,
and there's marital dissolution.
And there's deceit.
Like it's just like where you live,
you know,
it's exactly the same thing.
It's,
it's,
it's tyranny and catastrophe.
So that's great.
The tyrannical great father because
because Abraham ends up having to
sojourn in Egypt and,
and uh,
there's a feminine.
So Mother Nature is on the rampage and
Abraham lies about,
his wife has,
we'll see.
And so it's the world.
It's the world.
It's tyranny and,
and vulnerability and deceit.
And yet God says goal.
Because if you do go,
then you'll become a father of nations.
And you think,
well,
again,
that's pretty good news,
although it's strange because you'd
expect that if God chose Abraham,
then he'd send them immediately to the
land of honey land of milk.
And honey,
and that isn't what happens at all.
It doesn't happen at all and Abraham
never gets there,
but his mission is still regarded as
divine and thank God for that because
that's what your mission will be because
that's what you will encounter in your
life.
Those are the arc archetipal things.
Everyone encounters the tyranny of the
social structure and the and the
rapaciousness of nature and the
deceitful,
the deceitful quality of the human
psyche.
It's like that's the world.
Now.
It's a negative.
That's a negative view in some sense,
but it's positive in the story because
what it basically says is something
that's akin to the sermon on the mount,
which is that if you're aligned with God
and you pay attention to the divine
injunction,
then you can operate in the midst of
chaos and tyranny and deception and
flourish,
and you could hardly hope to have a
better piece of news than that.
Given that that's exactly where you are.
So and I didn't see any of that neighbor
having stories to begin with,
so that's been very interesting to have
that sort of reveal itself.
Abraham section nus develops the
personality and character of man to
integrate new degree in biblical
narrative.
Well picturing him in a new degree of
responsibility in him,
a new degree of responsibility.
So here's the other thing that's really
struck me and I think this is absolutely
crucial importance and I don't know how
much importance but it's certainly
important to me.
One of the things that has just blown me
away in the last year because I've
talked to lots of people,
lots of people live,
you know,
but also lots of people online but it's
more obvious live and it's obvious in
this theater as well as I've.
I've gone around and spoken and a large
proportion of my audience has been young
man young,
you know,
under 30,
something like that.
And I've spoken to them a lot about
responsibility.
And what's so odd about,
about this is that of all the things
that I've spoken about,
because I can see the audience and I can
feel how the audience is reacting
because I'm always paying attention to
all of you.
It's in so far as I can manage that.
So I,
I,
I get some sense of how,
what I'm saying is landing,
you know,
which you have to do if you're going to
speak effectively to people and what,
what happens is if I talk about
responsibilities,
everyone b is silent just like they are
now silent and not moving,
right?
Focusing attentive,
say pick up your responsibility,
pick up the heaviest thing you can and
carry it and the room goes quiet and
everybody's eyes open.
And I think that always makes somebody
break up.
I was,
I don't know why I was speaking to an
English journalist today who's going to
write an article in spectator magazine.
I was talking about this and at the same
point in the discussion the same,
I had the same emotional reaction.
I don't really understand it.
It's,
I think it's something.
There's something about it that's so
crucial because you know,
we've been fed this unending diet of
rights and freedoms and there's
something about that especially.
There's something about that that so
pathologically wrong and people are
starving for the antidote.
And the antidote is truth and
responsibility,
right?
And it isn't,
it isn't.
Because that's what you should do in
some,
you know,
in some,
some I know better or someone knows
better for you,
what you should do sense.
It's that.
It's that that's the secret to a
meaningful life and without a meaningful
life,
then all you have is suffering and
nihilism and despair and all of that and
self contempt and and that's not good
and so the man hits necessary for men to
stand up and take responsibility and
they all know that and and are starving
for that message and the message is more
that that's also a good thing to stand
up and take responsibility because
you're cursed so much.
Now from,
from,
from when you're young with this notion
that your active engagement with the
world is part of what is destroying and
undermining the planet and adding to the
tyranny of the social systems.
It's like,
how about not so much that,
hey,
because it's,
it's,
it's to soul deadening.
It's andy human right to the core and my
sense instead is that you know,
if you,
if you were able to reveal
the best of yourself to you in the
world,
that you would be an overwhelming force
for good and that whatever errors might
be made along the way would wash out in
the works,
and that's the other thing that you see
in the abrahamic stories because Abraham
is not a perfect person by any stretch
of the imagination.
He's a real person and he makes
mistakes,
but it doesn't matter.
The overarching narrative is,
you know,
maintain your covenant with God,
and despite your inadequacies,
then not only will you prevail,
but your descendants will prevail.
It's great.
That's really good news.
You know,
so it's been really something to see
that in the,
in the stories.
It's not that.
So that's responsibility.
It's not just that Abraham is kinder,
gentler,
more intrepid ethical or a better
debater than his ancestor noah.
Rather.
Both the Noah and Abraham,
stories or pieces of a development of an
increasingly stronger stance of humans
relative to the daddy before the story
is over,
humans will become a good deal,
stronger and bolder than Abraham,
and that's really something to say
because Abraham is pretty bold.
So we'll.
Let's read the stories.
The first one is about Abraham,
Sarah,
and lot.
Now these are the generations of Tara.
Tara begat a Ram,
so his name is Abraham to begin with,
and that actually turns out to be
important.
It's not Abraham knee,
Horton,
inherent,
inherent begat lot.
So heroin is Abrams.
Brother and heroin died before his
father,
terah in the land of his Nativity in Er
of the chaldees and Abraham and nay
whore took them wives.
The name of Abram's wife was Sarah and
the name of [inaudible] wife Milka,
the daughter of heroin,
the father of Milkah and the father of
Isca,
but Sarah was barren.
She had no child and Terah took Abraham,
his son and lot the son of heroin,
his son's son and daughter in law,
his son,
Abram's wife,
and they went forth with them from the
earth cellies from Irv,
the Chaldees to go into the land of
Canaan.
That's exile and they came into heroin
and dwelt there and the days of Terah
were 205 years and Terah died inherent
and there's a reason that Sarah is,
is introduced as barren and to set the
stage.
I think it was Anton Chekov who when he
was talking about this stage setting for
a play,
that if there was a rifle hanging on the
wall,
then it had better been used before.
I believe the second act or it shouldn't
be hanging there at all.
Right?
And so this is stage setting and part of
the reason that the biblical writers are
pointing out that Abram's wife is barren
is because it's a real catastrophe for
Abraham,
for Sarah as well,
that she's barren.
And so it's showing the trouble that
Abraham was in at the beginning of the
story.
And it's also.
It's also see what happens as the story
progresses is that Abraham,
Abraham and Sarah are eventually granted
his son,
but it's way late in the story and
they're very,
very old by the time it happens and of
course you're not going to be a father
of nations without having a child,
and so the the,
the writers
who are attempting to make the case that
if you forthrightly pursue that which
God directs you to pursue,
let's say that all things are possible.
That's the idea and the narrative and
you might say that's naive and you know
it.
It's not it.
You think when you're naive,
right,
and then you dispense with that idea and
then when you stop being the sort of
person who dispenses with ideas,
then you come to another place and
that's the place where you think you
have no idea what might be possible for
you.
If you,
if you've got things together and
pursued what you should pursue,
you don't know how much what's
impossible to you right now would become
possible under those conditions.
It's an unknown phenomena and like I've
watched people who've put themselves
together across time incrementally and
continually and they become capable of
things that are jaw,
not only jaw,
droppingly amazing,
but also sometimes metaphysically
impossible to understand and so we don't
know the limits of human endeavor.
We truly don't,
and it it's premature to put a cap on
what it is that we are,
what,
what it is that we're capable of.
And so you,
you know,
you're already something and maybe
you're not so bad in your current
configuration,
but you may wonder if you did nothing
for the next 30 years except put
yourself together just exactly what
would you be able to do and you might
think,
well,
that's worth finding out.
But of course that's,
that's the adoption of responsibility.
And one thing I've also learned over the
years because I've been curious about
this battle between meaning and
nihilism.
You know,
and I mean I could see for a long while
the rationale in nihilism and the power
of the nihilistic argument,
but it,
it,
it occurred to me across time that
despite that the power of the nihilistic
argument is more powerful than naive
optimism,
but it's not more powerful than the
optimism that is not naive because the
optimism that is not naive says it's
self evident that the world is a place
of suffering and that there are things
to be done about that and it's self
evident that people are flawed and that
there's things to be done about that.
And then the non naive optimist says the
suffering could be reduced and the
insufficient c could be overcome if
people oriented themselves properly and
did what they were capable of doing.
And I do not believe that that's
deniable.
I do.
I think that human potential is
virtually limitless and that there's
nothing,
perhaps it's beyond our grasp before
careful as individuals and as a society.
And so I think that there's no reason
for nihilism and there's no reason for
hopelessness and,
and there's no reason to bow down before
evil because we're capable of so much
more.
And I think that you can easily,
you know that first because you're not
happy with who you are and you're
ashamed and embarrassed about it as you
should be.
And you know it because if look out
there,
you see people who are capable of doing
great things and you know that we're not
giving it our all and still we're not
doing so badly,
you know?
And so you might wonder if,
if,
if we devoted 90 percent of our effort
to putting things right instead of 55
percent of our effort,
or maybe even less than that,
you might wonder just how well could
things be put together.
And I think that you can figure that out
by starting with your room,
by the way.
And the Lord said unto Abraham,
and this is the,
this is the opening of the story.
Get thee out of thy country and from thy
kindred and from thy Father's House unto
a land that I will show the.
And this is one of those phrases where
every clause is significant.
Go somewhere you don't understand.
That's the first thing.
Get thee out of thy country.
You know,
back in the 19 twenties there was a
whole slew of American writers who ended
up as expatriates in Paris,
hemingway among them,
and who wrote the Great Gatsby,
Fitzgerald,
yes.
And then a variety of others.
It was very inexpensive in Paris at the
time and part of their transformation
into great literary figures was the fact
that they were out of their country and
now they could see what their country
was because you can't see what your
country is until you leave it.
So you have to go into the unknown and
that's God's first command.
Go into the unknown because you already
know what you know and so and that's not
enough unless you think you're enough.
And if you're not enough and you don't
think you're enough,
then you have to go where you haven't
been.
And so that's the first commandment to
Abraham.
It's like,
okay,
that's a good one.
That makes perfect sense.
Go to where you don't know.
Yes.
And from my kindred will that.
What does that mean?
It means grow up,
right?
That's what it means.
It means get away from your family
enough so that you can establish your
independence.
And that isn't because there's something
wrong with your family.
Although perhaps there is,
you know,
as long as there is perhaps wrong with
you,
but it means get away.
You know,
I talked to people very frequently whose
families have provided them with too
much protection and they know it
themselves and that means they're
deprived of necessity.
You know,
one of the things that you see in,
in the United States for example,
is that the children are first
generation immigrants often do better
than the,
than their children.
And the reason for that is that the
children are first generation
immigrants,
have necessity driving them.
And you don't know how much you need
necessity to drive you because maybe
you're not very disciplined.
And if a catastrophe doesn't immediately
be fall,
you,
if you don't act forthrightly today,
then maybe you'll never act
forthrightly,
right?
Because the gap between your foolishness
and the punishment is,
is lengthened by your unearned wealth.
And so you never grow up and learn and
you have to get yourself away from your
dependency in order to allow necessity
to drive you forward.
And that's to become independent and to
become mature.
And I think part of what's happening in
our culture is that the,
the,
the force that's attacking the
forthright movement forward of young men
in particular is afraid of the power of
man because it's confused about the
distinction between power and authority
and competence.
Like I know a man who's who has
authority and competence has power as a
byproduct,
but the authority and competence,
everything and,
and,
and people who can't understand that
fail to make the distinction between
power and authority of competence and
they're afraid of power.
And so they destroy authority and
competence.
And that's a terrible thing because we
need authority and competence.
What else is going to.
What else is going to allow us to
prevail?
In the long run,
and so you get away from your country
and you get away from your kin and from
your father's house,
right?
And you go out there and you establish
yourself in the world.
It's a call to adventure.
That's what this the first lines in the
Abrahamic story is a call to adventure.
So great unto a land that I will show
you.
Well,
you know,
what does that mean?
You know?
One of the things that I've been struck
very hard by a number of writers,
Carl Young,
obviously among them,
I mean he,
he wrote things like Nisha,
that if you understand them,
they just break you into pieces and one
of the things that young understood in
the psychoanalysts understand it's one
of the most terrifying elements of
psychoanalytic thinking is very tightly
allied with religious thinking,
which is that you are not the master of
your own house.
There are spirits that dwelling within
you,
meaning you have a will and you can
exercise a certain amount of conscious
control over your being,
but there are all sorts of things that
occur within you that seem to be beyond
your capacity to control your dreams.
For example,
that's a really good example.
Are Your impulses.
For example,
you might,
you might think of those as so foreign
from you that they're not even.
You don't even want them to be part of
you,
but,
but more subtly even.
How about what you're interested in?
What compels you?
Like,
where does that come from?
Exactly.
Because you can't.
God,
you can't conjure it up of your own
accord.
You know?
So if you're a student in,
you're taking difficult course,
you might say to yourself,
well,
I need to sit down and study for three
hours,
but then you sit down and that is what
happens.
Your attention goes everywhere and you
might say,
well,
whose attention is it?
Then?
If it goes everywhere because you say
it's your attention,
it's like,
well,
if it's your attention,
maybe you will be able to control it,
but you can't.
And so then you might think,
well jen and just exactly what the hell
is controlling it.
And you might say,
well,
it's random.
It's,
well,
I better not be random.
I can tell you that that's.
That happens to some degree in
schizophrenia.
There's an element of randomness in
that.
It's not random.
It's driven by the action of phenomena
that I think are best considered as
something like subpersonalities or
they'll even only a partial description.
You can't make yourself interested in
something.
Interest manifests itself in grips you.
That's a whole different thing.
And so what is it that's gripping you
and how do you conceptualize that?
Is that a divine power?
Well,
it's divine as far as your concern
because it grips you and you can't do
anything about it.
And so there's a calling in you towards
what you're compelled by and what you're
interested in.
And sometimes that might be very dark
and sometimes not,
but you're compelled forward by your
interest.
And so and so the idea that what moves
you away from your country and your
father's house and the comforts of your
childhood home is,
is something that's beyond you.
And that you listened to in Harken to.
That's exactly right.
And you can say,
well,
I don't want to call it that God.
It's like it doesn't matter what you
call it.
Exactly.
It doesn't matter to what it is,
what it's called.
It still is,
and if you don't listen to it,
that's the other thing.
If you don't listen to it,
and I've been a clinician and talked to
enough people now as old as I am,
to know this.
Absolutely.
If you do not listen to that thing that
beckons you forward,
you will pay for it like you cannot
possibly imagine.
You'll have everything that's terrible
about life in your life and nothing
about it that's good and worse.
You'll know that it was your fault and
that you squandered what you could have
had.
So this is not only a calling forth,
but a warning unto a land that I will
show the and that's it,
that I will show the that.
And you don't want to be too concrete
about this.
You know,
there's all sorts of new territories
that you can inhabit.
If you.
There's this abstract and conceptual
territory of Gilda University and you
study biology or you studied physics or
or any discipline.
You're in a territory,
right?
You're in the territory that all of the
scholars have established,
and then as you master the discipline,
you move out beyond the established
territory,
into the unknown,
and that's a new land,
right?
Maybe it's even a land of your enemies
for that matter,
but it's a new land to the frontier is
always in front of you.
And so you know when the earth was less
inhabited than it is now.
The frontier was the psychological
frontier and the geographical frontier
was the same thing and now they've
separated to some degree because there's
not so much geographical frontier,
but there's the frontier is a place that
never disappears and the land that's
beyond the land that you know is always
there.
And it's always where you should go.
And all of that packed into these four
phrases so well.
So when I've been thinking about
narrative,
you look at the world through a story,
you can't,
you can't help it.
And this story is what gives value to
the world or or the stories,
what you extract from the value of the
world.
You can look at it either way,
you're somewhere and it's not good
enough,
right?
That's the eternal human predicament.
Wherever you are,
isn't good enough.
And to some degree that's actually a
good thing because if it was good
enough,
well there's nothing for you to do.
So it's actually maybe a good thing that
it's insufficient.
And that might be why sometimes having
less iss is better than having more.
I don't want to be a pollyanna about
that.
I mean,
I know that there's deprivation that can
reach to the point where it's no where
it's completely counterproductive,
but it isn't always the case that
starting with little is you.
If you start with little,
you start with more possibility.
It's something like that.
So you move from always from what's
unbearable about the present to some
better future.
Right?
And if you don't have that,
then you have no,
you have nothing but threatened and
negative emotion.
You have no positive emotion because the
positive emotion is generated in the
conception of the better future and then
the evidence that you generate yourself,
that you're moving towards it.
That's where the positive and fulfilling
meaning of life comes.
So you want to set up this structure
properly.
It's very,
very important and so what it means is
that you want to be going somewhere
that's good enough so that the going is
worth the while and you can ask yourself
that,
and that's partly what we tried to build
into the future authoring program,
which is,
well,
we know what's wrong with life.
It's rife with suffering and
insufficiency in deception and evil.
It's all of that obviously.
Okay,
what would make the journey worthwhile?
Or you can ask yourself that.
It's like,
alright,
in order to bear up hundred this load,
what is it that I would need to be
striving to attain?
And if you ask yourself that,
that's to knock and the door will open.
That's what that means.
If you ask yourself that,
then you will find an answer and you'll
think you'll shrink away from it.
You'll think,
well,
there's no way I could do that.
It's like,
well,
you don't know what you could do.
You don't know what's possible and
you're not as much as you could be,
and so god only knows what you could,
what you could do and have and give if
you sacrificed everything to it.
And that's the reason that Abraham is
constantly making sacrifices and it's
archaic,
right?
He's burning up like baby lambs,
but like while they're alive,
you know that something and they're
valuable and that's something,
it's you have to admit,
even if you think about it as a modern
person,
that the act of sacrificing something
might have some dramatic compulsion to
it.
You know,
to go out into a flock and to take
something that's new board and to cut
its throat into bleed it into burn.
It might be a way of indicating to
yourself that you're actually serious
about something and it isn't so obvious
that we have rituals of seriousness like
that now.
And so it's not so obvious that we're
actually serious about anything.
And so maybe that's not such a good
thing.
And so maybe we shouldn't be thinking
that these people were so archaic and
primitive and superstitious.
It's possible that they knew something
that we don't.
It's certainly in the abrahamic stories.
One of the things that maintains
Abraham's covenant with God is his
continual,
a willingness to sacrifice it.
It's so that sacrificial issue is so
important because you are not committed
to something unless you're willing to
sacrifice for it.
Commitment and sacrifice are the same
thing and I think its borders on
miraculous that those concepts are
embedded into this narrative at the
level of dramatic action.
You know,
instead of abstract explanation,
people are acting this out and then the
fundamental conception is so profound
that it's really quite.
It's quite inspiring and it's
breathtaking really,
when you understand what message is
trying to be conveyed,
you have to make sacrifices and what do
you have to sacrifice?
You have to sacrifice that which is most
valuable to you currently that stopping
you and God only knows what that is.
It's certainly the worst of you.
It's certainly that and god only knows
to what degree you're in love with the
worst of you.
So well,
so you moved from the unbearable present
to the ideal future and and you can't
help that.
You have to live in a structure like
that.
That's your house,
that's another way of thinking about it
and if you want to get your house in
order and if you want it to be a place
that you can live properly,
then you have to plan the future.
That is perfect.
And then I think,
well what does that mean?
It means it's good for you.
Right?
And one of the things that I do all the
time with my clinical and consulting
clients is try to figure out what would
be good for them,
but we do more than that.
We try to think,
okay,
well what,
how can we set this up so it's really
good for you and that all the side
consequences of that are things that are
good for other people.
And so because people are often also
timid about trying to get something
that's good for themselves because they
feel that it's selfish or that they
don't deserve it.
So we set it up so that.
Well,
look,
we're going to set it up so that it's
plainly obvious that this will not harm
the structure of the universe for you to
have what you need and to do it in a way
that's of benefit to other people.
There's no downside to that and and so
it's okay.
It's okay if you reach out and take
that.
And one of the things that's interesting
about the biblical stories,
Abrahamic stories as well as the God
doesn't really seem to be opposed to the
success of the people that he's chosen.
You know what happens to them as,
as they progress through their journey,
as they get larger flocks and they get
more authority and they get,
they get more,
they get life more abundant.
That's what happens.
It's God isn't,
doesn't seem to be a miser in the old
testament.
It's like if you put in the effort and
you and you accept the covenant and you
make the sacrifices,
then you get to be successful and maybe
successful beyond your wildest dreams
and that that's actually seems to be
okay with God and that's pretty cool
given that you know,
that the general notion of Old Testament
God is that all he's doing is casting
out curses in death,
you know,
wherever he happens to wander.
And I mean there's certainly no shortage
of that,
but.
But again,
it seems to me that that's very good
news and that you also don't have to be
perfect in order for to have that
happen.
And then the other thing,
this is the issue about going into the
unknown.
It's like,
well,
if you leave your country and your kin
and your father's house and you go out
into a land that your intuition guides
you to,
you're going to undergo these radical
transformations.
This is a sacrificial transformation too
because you're moving forthrightly and
voluntarily into chaos.
Right?
And that's the same as the dragon fight.
That's the hero's story.
And what will happen there is that you
will transform yourself,
and so the call to an ideal is also the
call to a sequence of deaths and
rebirths that move you closer and closer
to the ideal.
And that's what that's what God is
calling Abraham to do.
In the first sentence of this story,
you see these things echoed
in the strangest places.
And so these are stills that I took from
Pinocchio and this little cricket.
So he is this still small voice,
right?
That's the thing that calls to you.
It's your conscious conscience in part,
it's your intuition in part,
and it's the thing that opens up the
great book of the world,
the great sacred book of the world.
And that's what happens here,
right?
And the animators are at pains to show
you that it's a leather bound book with
guilt lettering.
It's a valuable book and it's something
that's quiet that's showing it to you,
right?
You have to meditate.
Let's say you have to be somewhere where
the world isn't drowning you out in
order to understand how to open this,
to listen to that voice that tells you
where you should go with what you should
do next,
and then what happens is that something
beckons to you in the night.
It's a star,
right?
It's something that transcends the
horizon.
It's,
it's glitters,
it's brilliant.
It's not day to day it.
It's something that's beyond you.
It's something that represents a
transcendent ideal and that makes it
manifest to you.
If you're quiet enough to listen and
that's what you wish upon so strangely,
right,
and people do that they wish upon a
star,
they teach their children that and they
don't know why.
What do you mean you wish upon a star?
What in the world does that mean?
It means you lift your eyes to the
heavens and make a pact with the
transcendent and then your and then what
your heart's desire will come to you.
That's what it means and you think,
well,
that's so.
That's not naive.
It's the most sophisticated thing that
you can know and it's the birth of the
hero,
right?
Because that's the.
That's the Nativity star obviously,
and this is where it takes place.
It's just
anywhere and the person who is just a
carpenter and a toy maker,
but that's pretty good at carpenter.
If you're a deceitful carpenter than
your house falls down and if you're a
toy maker then you love children.
It's a good start.
You know?
So.
So Japan who lives in this little,
it's,
it's a,
it's not a grand house,
it's,
it's just an everyday house,
but everything that's happening and it
is good and so that means it's a palace
because everything in it is how that's
happening is good.
There's a saying and I don't remember
where it comes from.
Then it's better to have bread and water
in peace than a feast in conflict.
And like that's not a saying,
that's just the starkest possible
description of the truth because there's
nothing worse than eating a grande meal
with people you hate and despise that
are at each other's throats.
It's much better to have bread and water
in peace.
It's,
it's not,
it's,
it's just clearheaded analysis of the
structure of the world to say things
like that,
and so the magical transformation can
happen in the most mundane of places
because,
and the reason for that is that the
mundane nature of places is an illusion
because every place is the potential
birthplace of the Kingdom of God.
That's the case and so Japan,
he's a good guy.
He has a kitten.
The kitten likes them.
He makes puppets and he's humble person
and he knows that compared to the ideal
that he's attempting to subscribe to,
that he's.
He's not a based before it or anything
like that.
He's not despicable in relationship to
it,
but the reason he's on his knees is
because the thing he's pointing at is
above him.
You know,
if he.
It wouldn't be the right aim if it
wasn't above him and so the fact that
he's on his knees so to speak,
is only an indication that his aim is
proper because you should be on your
knees to something that you actually
admire.
And if you don't feel like being on your
knees in front of it,
then perhaps you don't actually admire
it,
and then that means you haven't got the
stage set properly.
It could be.
It should be something that fills you
with all your aim should,
should be add something that fills you
with all because what?
Why do something else while perhaps
because it's easy and perhaps because
it's malevolent and all of those things,
but,
but those are no answer to the problems
that beset you.
They just make things worse and that's
clear.
And so then Japan will have as having
made his packed his covenant,
just like Abraham,
he falls into a dream,
right?
He falls into a dream and the rest of
the movie actually takes place in a
dream.
And it's a dream.
It's the dream within which
transformation takes place and that's
laid out,
at least in part time stops in,
in the Pinocchio Story and everything
happens to Pinocchio in some sense in
Atlanta,
that's outside of normal time.
And that's,
that's the infinite archetipal space.
And that's a real place.
That's a real place.
The infinite and the finite coexist and
most of the time we're in the place of
the finite,
but that doesn't mean that the place of
infinite doesn't exist.
It just means that we can't get access
to it.
We just get intimations of it.
From time to time,
you know when things are going perfectly
well for you on those rare occasions
where everything comes together for the
brief moment,
you inhabit that divine place and you
have some sense of what your life could
be like if you organized it from
smallest element to the largest element
and that's a place that you can inhabit,
if not forever,
in a manner that at least felt like
forever.
Well,
because of Japan was decisioned,
the transcendent manifests itself.
It takes the form of the blue fairy
here.
That's the positive element of nature,
right?
So we could say,
well,
nature,
it's not so clear that she's on your
side,
right?
She's the Red Queen in Alice in
wonderland who runs around screaming.
When you go down the rabbit hole,
she runs around screaming off with their
heads and who says,
in my kingdom,
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place.
That's mother nature,
but then we might say,
well,
how do we know that Mother Nature's
attitude towards you isn't negative
because your attitude towards things
isn't proper and that's what this film
attempts to indicate.
The idea is that if you aim properly,
then nature aligns itself behind you.
Now it also a raise itself in front of
you,
perhaps even as an antagonist,
but the power that it it,
it provides you with from within might
be sufficient to overcome it from
without.
And I think that I think that the
clinical evidence is clear about that
because one of the things that we do
know is that if you take people who are
confronting terrible things and
shrinking from them and you teach them
how to structure their behavior so that
they can advance with courage.
Everything works better for them.
Their fears decrease and their character
grows and so there might be enough of
nature within us to help us withstand
the nature that's outside of us and it
depends,
at least to some degree on how it is
that we orient ourselves in the world to
some to some unknowable degree.
Now
Japan warrants an autonomous individual
as a son
and that's also something that makes him
a great person because autonomous
individuals have their own will and if
you're a tyrant,
it's the last thing that you're going to
want and if you're the tyrant who's
jealous of his son,
it's even more so the last thing you're
ever going to want and so to aim high
and to want the development of the
autonomous individual or the same thing,
and I would say that's the core story in
some sense of of Western culture is to
aim high and to develop the autonomous
individual or the same thing and that's
what happens in Pinocchio.
That's what happens in the story of
Abraham and the transformation takes
place.
The Magical Transformation and the
Pinocchio Story.
One of the things that's so interesting
about it,
and this is part of it's mythological
substructure from the scientific
perspective,
there's only two determining forces with
regards to the destiny of the
individual.
There's nature,
deterministic and culture,
deterministic and then scholars wrangle
about which of those is the greater
force,
but in mythological stories there's
always a third element.
The third element is something like
autonomous consciousness and there's no
place for autonomous consciousness in
the deterministic story of nature and
culture,
but we all act as if autonomy is
consciousness,
is the primary reality and the biblical
stories are predicated on the idea that
autonomous consciousness is what gives
rise to the world and I don't think that
we're in a position to presume that that
is necessarily an error,
and so what that means is to aim high
and to develop the autonomous individual
is six is simultaneously the decision to
formulate an allegiance with the
conscious power that brings being into
existence and that all takes place
inside this little puppet and then he
has his adventures,
right?
He's,
he's,
he's still half jackass and half
deceptive,
but he's still.
Despite that,
despite all the errors,
he has the capacity to move forward and
to transform into something to transform
himself into something that can be
properly considered described as a true
son of God and that's the right aim
and it works like this.
As far as I can tell.
You know,
when I talked to people about doing the
future authoring program,
they often put it off and it's not
surprising because it's hard and,
and be,
but it's more than that.
They think,
well,
I don't know how to write.
I'm going to do a bad job.
I don't really like assignments.
I'm going to have to do it perfectly.
I need to wait until I have enough time
and like one of those is enough to stop
you cold and all five of them you're
just done.
And so I tell people do it haphazardly,
a tiny bit at a time and badly because
you can do that.
I tell my students when they're doing
their thesis master's thesis,
write a really bad first draft and then
we have a little conversation about that
because they don't think.
I mean that because it sounds like a
cliche in some sense.
It's not a cliche.
It's not a cliche at all.
It means
you're a terrible writer,
but,
but if someone put a gun to your head
and said,
you have to have your a hundred page
thesis done by next Monday,
or I'll shoot you,
but I don't care how terrible it is,
you would sit down and write it and the
thing is then you have it right then,
then you have something and then you can
fix it.
You can iterate and fix it.
That bad first draft.
That's the most valuable thing,
and so that's what you need.
You need a bad first draft of yourself
and there's.
There's an idea in the young developed
about the trickster and the gesture,
the comedian,
right?
That the trickster is the precursor to
the savior and that's one of the things
I learned from young that was just.
It's so unlikely you'd never think that
it's so amazing that that might be the
case,
but the,
the,
the satirical and the erotic and the and
the troublemaker that the comedian,
the fool,
the fool is the precursor to the savior.
Why?
Because you're a fool when you start
something new and so if you're not
willing to be a fool,
then you'll never start anything new,
and if you never started anything new,
then you won't develop.
And so the willingness to be a fool is
the precursor to transformation and
that's the same as humility.
And so if you're going to write your
destiny,
you can do a bad first job.
You're going to get smarter as you move
forward.
That's the thing is that so something
beckons to you.
That's what happens here.
Maybe the star that you pedal wished on
was the wrong damn star,
but at least it was a star,
right?
At least it was in the sky.
At least it moved him forward and so you
say in your life or something grips you
and fills you with interest and you
think,
well,
should I do that?
And the answer is,
if not that,
then something.
What if it's a mistake?
It's a mistake.
Rest assured,
what do you know?
You're going to stumble around,
right?
And what's going to happen is this,
you're going to move to,
you're going to not stay in spaces,
you're not going to wander around in
circles.
And I see people like that.
They said,
well,
I never knew what to do,
and now I'm 40 so that's not so good.
That's not so good.
And you might say,
well,
and there is literature to that suggests
that people are a lot more unhappy when
they look back in their lives about the
things they didn't do than they are
about the mistakes they made while they
were doing things.
And so that's really worth thinking
about too because there's redemptive
mistakes and a redemptive mistake would
be a mistake that you make when you go
out and try to do something.
You know,
you actually,
you think,
okay,
I'm going to try to do this.
When you're not good at it,
you make a bunch of mistakes.
It's like,
what's the consequence if you pay
attention is you're not quite so stupid
anymore.
That's the thing is you've been informed
by your,
by the results of your errors,
and so what happens is you,
you follow the beacon,
you follow the light and you're blind so
you don't know where the light is.
It's dimly apprehended only and you're
afraid to follow it,
but you decided to take some stumbling
steps towards it and as you take
stumbling steps towards it,
you become illuminated and enlightened
and informed because of the nature of
your experience,
because you're pushing yourself beyond
where you are and you're going into the
country that you have not yet been in
and you learn something,
and so what happens then is the star
moves.
You move 10 feet towards it and you
think,
no,
that's not right.
I didn't get it right.
It isn't there.
It's actually there,
and so then you,
you see it somewhere else and you shift
yourself slightly and you move forward
and that's what happens is that you
continue as you changed the thing that
guides you forward,
moves,
right?
It's like God in in the,
in the desert,
in Egypt,
the pillar of light that you're
following gets moving.
It's not a permanent thing.
You move towards it,
it moves away.
It guides you forward and so you say,
well,
is what I'm aiming at paradise itself.
And the answer to that is no,
because what do you know?
You see you couldn't see paradise if it
was right in front of you,
but you might get a glimmer of it and so
you move towards it and you grow and
then the next time you open your eyes
you see a little bit more clearly and
that's what happens is that just happens
over and over,
right?
It keeps moving
and so you move like this,
but the thing that's so cool is that all
those zigs and zags you say on each of
those Zags,
zigs is a catastrophe.
I hit a wall,
my God,
and then I had to die a little bit and I
barely got back up.
It's a phoenix transformation at each,
at each turn,
and it's painful,
but the thing is is that even though
you've.
You've traveled 20 miles,
let's say on that road,
and you've only moved three miles
forward.
You've moved three miles forward instead
of falling backwards,
because that's the thing too is that if
you stand still,
you fall backwards.
You cannot stand still because the world
moves away from you.
If you stand still and there's no
status,
there's only backwards and so if you're
not moving backward,
back,
forwards,
then you're moving backwards and that's
more more of the underlying truth of the
matthew principle to those who have
everything more will be given from those
who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
It's a warning.
Do not stay in one place.
Well as you zig and zag,
maybe the maybe the cataclysm of each
transformation starts to lessen.
There's not so much of you that has to
die with every mistake
and maybe you end up oriented at least
reasonably properly,
and if you were sensible,
that would have been your trip,
but it wasn't right.
It's that and perhaps it's a lot worse,
did not.
Perhaps there's no shortage of
backtracking,
but it doesn't matter because as you
stumble forward,
you,
you illuminated and inform yourself,
and perhaps that's partly because the
world is made of information and if you
encounter it and tangle with it than it
informs you and then you become informed
and then your information and then
you're ready,
and so God says to Abraham,
I will make of thee a great nation and I
will bless thee and make thy name great
and thou shalt be a blessing.
That's,
that's a good offer.
Fundamentally,
I mean it.
It means
what does it mean to to be made a great
nation of?
Well,
perhaps it has something to do directly
with your descendants,
but I don't think it's just that you
know,
is if you're a force for good in the
world,
then that radiates out from you and if
you're good enough,
it's difficult to say how much of an
impact on things you could have.
You know Dostoevsky,
who was a very crazy person,
partly because of his epilepsy,
he said,
a man is not only responsible for
everything he does,
but for everything that everyone else
does,
and you think,
well,
no,
and yes,
sometimes no.
Sometimes that's what you think of your
cataclysmic,
really depressed,
right,
is that your sins are so egregious that
they're unforgivable and that in some
manner you're at,
you're at fault for everything that's
terrible with the world,
but there's actually truth in that and
there's actually redemptive truth in
that is that things wouldn't be so bad
if you weren't so if you weren't so far
from what you could be,
and that's terribly pessimistic because
it's all on you,
man,
but it's terribly optimistic because
God,
there's a lot of things that you could
do and if you're crying out for
something to do,
then that's the best news you could
possibly have.
It's like things aren't so good,
but neither are you.
So if you stopped doing the things that
you knew to be destructive,
which is the right place to start.
You know,
if you're going to clean up your room,
what do you do first while you just get
rid of the mess,
you know when you know what no one has
to come in and tell you.
Hopefully what's the worst mass?
It's just it announces itself to you and
you can certainly know yourself and this
is a very easy meditative exercise to
sit down and think,
okay,
I'm doing one thing really stupidly that
I should stop doing.
It's like,
how long is it going to take you to
figure out what that is?
It's about two seconds,
right?
You've known it forever.
Then you could even make it less
demanding.
You could say,
there was some stupid things that I'm
doing that I know are stupid and wrong
that I could stop doing that I would
stop doing,
and then you can just start with that
and you can just do that and maybe it's
just a little thing.
Although it's not because it's,
it's a.
it's a step forward on the proper
voyage.
It's not a small thing and you think,
well,
what would happen?
You could say,
let's do this for a year or even a
month,
just try not to do things,
you know,
to be stupid and wrong for a month.
And that means not to say things you
know,
to be stupid and wrong as well.
Maybe that's the most important thing.
Just do it as an experiment,
see what happens.
And it's so fun because I have people
writing to me from all over the world
who are saying they're doing that.
They're saying,
well,
you know,
I cleaned up my room and,
and then I stopped saying stupid things
and my God,
it's like things are way better.
It's like who would have guessed it?
You know?
And so it's low hanging fruit man,
because there's,
that's the other thing.
If there's a lot of things wrong with
you,
then it's really easy to start fixing
it.
You know,
you've got so much.
There's so much territory that you can
inhabit.
I will make of thee a great nation.
I will bless thee.
That's good.
I mean the whole nation thing that's
positive,
but to have God on your side,
that's you know,
you might want that when things get
rough,
that would be good and make their name
great and thou shalt be a blessing.
Wonderful.
That's a good deal,
and I will bless them that bless thee.
That's good too,
and curse him that curses thee and in
these shallow families of the earth,
be blessed.
That's something that's something that
wouldn't be something.
If you could wake up and your day was
composed in part of people thanking you
for all the good things you've done in
the world,
would that be good?
It's not impossible for that to happen.
So Abraham departed.
Yes.
As the Lord had spoken unto him and lot
went with him and Abraham was 70 and
five years when he departed out of her
own.
That's all old now.
Abraham lives a long time,
but this is also part of the story.
So he has a wife who can't have
children.
He has nothing.
Obviously.
He's been hanging around.
Dad's shocked for a little too long
given that he's 75,
right?
It's time.
It's time to get on the fire,
lit underneath him a bit and so he's not
got much going for him,
but he still decides to to move forward
and I've seen this too,
you know,
like if you don't have your destiny in
hand by your time you're 30,
it's,
it's rough.
You start hurting and if you don't have
your destiny in hand by the time you're
40,
then you really start hurting and
forties,
a real fork in the road.
The fork in the road.
That's always where you meet the devil
by the way.
And that's because every time you have
to make a decision,
the possibility of evil beckons.
That's why that is.
I had a friend,
I've told you a little about him and he
killed himself just after 40.
No,
he had had a book published with a very
small press.
He was quite a good writer,
but he could not get himself together
and it hit him too hard at 40.
And I'm not saying that it's hopeless at
40.
I'm not saying that.
I'm not saying that partly because of
these verses,
but also partly because of what I've
seen in my clinical practice.
I've had people come to me who have had
very chaotic and the ill spent lives,
let's say,
who were in that neighborhood of age and
and it's true for people who are older
as well,
who then decided to make a real effort
and to try to make where they were
better.
You know,
instead of being bitter about where they
weren't because that's the bitterness
that really does you,
when it's really not good.
It's the opposite of gratitude.
It's,
it's,
it's the manifestation of resentment
that makes you malevolent.
It's very,
very bad to be better.
It's not,
it's not.
It's hell to be bitter,
and if you're 40 and you're not
successful,
then you have to accept your lot and you
have to start to improve what's right in
front of you and if you do that,
it doesn't take very long.
It's quite interesting to watch people.
Things can be a lot better in six months
and they can be way better in two years.
It's a struggle,
uphill struggle,
but it's by no means impossible and I
don't know again what the limit of that
is.
I suppose it depends on the degree to
some degree on the degree of your
commitment,
but anyway,
so aber,
it's another indication of the real
validity of this story.
God isn't setting this up to be easy,
right?
Abraham was old and he and and his and
his wife is old too,
and more than that,
she's barren.
How is he going to be the father of
nations?
How is he going to be successful?
Well,
the initial departure point is
insufficient,
radically insufficient,
and,
and that's very inspiring because it
means that you can start from where you
are.
So Abraham departed,
as the Lord had spoken unto him and lot
went with him and Abraham was 75 years
old when he departed out of her around
and Abraham took Sarah,
his wife and lot his brother's son and
all their substance that they had
gathered.
And you know,
he has a relationship with law,
right?
And he doesn't have his own son,
but he,
his brother died and so he takes his
nephew as his son that's grateful,
you know,
did he could be very angry and have
nothing to do with them because he
didn't get his own son.
But that isn't,
that isn't what happens is he's offered
to substitute let's say,
and he accepts it and so good for him,
you know?
And that's.
And that's also something that I've seen
that characterize as people who can make
the best of a bad lot is they don't get
exactly what they want,
but something comes along that offers
possibilities that are sufficient
perhaps if exploited properly,
and they open their heart and welcomed
them in instead of rejecting them in
bitterness.
And so that's a good thing.
And that's part of Abraham's character.
And Abraham took Sarah,
his wife and lot his brother's son and
all their substance that they had
gathered and all the souls that they had
gotten in her.
And,
and they went forth to go into the land
of Canaan into exile,
let's say,
and into the land of Canaan.
They came.
And that's another repetition of the
transformation story,
right?
You have to go to a land where you're
not welcome
an apron pass through the land unto the
place of Chm onto the plane of Maura and
the Canaanite was then in the land and
the Lord appeared unto Abraham and said
unto thy seed,
I will give you this land.
And there he built an altar to the Lord
who appeared unto him and he removed
from thence onto a mountain on the east
of Bethel and pitched his tent having
Bethel on the west and high on the east.
And there he built an altar unto the
Lord and called upon the name of the
Lord.
Now we don't understand these rituals
precisely.
You know,
I don't know if the people who did this
engaged in a meditative ritual was not
the idea that you take something of
value.
You do this,
you,
you undertake this dramatic
transformation of a life and death
transformation.
And is that an aid to meditation?
And what do you do?
Do you sit down and think?
Do you,
do you pray?
Pray being to ask,
you know,
to what do I do next?
How do I orient myself in the world as a
useful exercise to do that too.
I think it's something that people could
do every morning.
I think it's useful to sit down and
think,
okay,
what's the most important thing I should
do today?
What I have an array of things that call
to me to be done,
some of which I will do with joy and
some of which I will bear as
responsibilities,
but they array themselves in front of me
and what should I attend to first?
Well,
do you ask or do you decide and it seems
to me when I do it because I do it all
the time.
I do it every morning.
I try to sit down and think,
okay,
I've got things that I would like to do
and things that call to me out of
necessity,
what do I do first?
And it's not so much a decision as it is
a question and I don't know what I'm
calling on.
It's I'm calling on my capacity to think
I suppose,
but that's not my capacity exactly.
I,
I can,
I can commune with whatever provides the
answers and I can think that that's me
thinking,
but,
and now it isn't that I believe that.
I can't think.
I do believe that I can consciously
think,
but that's not the same as calling for
inspiration.
It's not the same process.
Just like a dream is not conscious
thinking.
It's something that happens to you and
that kind of inspiration is also
something that happens to you because I
asked myself,
well,
what's the most important thing I could
do next?
And then I have an answer to that,
but it isn't because I decided exactly.
I've decided that I'll do it,
whatever it is and that I want to know
what it is.
Those are the decisions,
but.
But there's an involuntary aspect to the
sorting that occurs and that's the
psychological equivalent I suppose to
this.
And I guess the sacrifice is when I feel
that I will do whatever it is that calls
to be done.
Then I don't do the other things that I
might want to do.
And that's a sacrifice.
It's to me it's the proper sacrifice
because my sense is that things don't go
properly unless you do what's most
important and if I want things to go
properly and I do because I've had my
taste of things not going properly,
I want things to go properly and so then
it's not so difficult to do what's
necessary to to do what makes things go
properly under those circumstances and
it's hardly.
See,
this is partly why the story of Sodom
and Gomorrah is embedded in the
abrahamic stories,
I think because that's an apocalyptic
story,
right?
If things go badly enough,
the whole city is destroyed.
Okay,
and then and
the reason it goes badly,
it's because the people in the city do
not behave properly and the people in
the city might be you.
And so if you're not behaving properly,
then you go and so does the city and
maybe you don't want.
Maybe you do want that,
but maybe you don't want that and if you
don't want that,
then maybe.
And you know that if you don't do things
property,
then it's Un the city.
If you actually know that,
then maybe that terrifies you badly
enough so that you're willing to make
the sacrifice to do the right things
instead of the impulsive things that you
might otherwise want to do.
You know,
I learned from Viktor Frankl in from
Carl Yogan,
from Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn and for many
of the people whose works on the
Holocaust that I read and on the
catastrophes in the Soviet Union,
and the people who'd studied most deeply
always came to the same conclusion.
The state became corrupted because each
individual allowed themselves to be
corrupted or perhaps participated
joyfully in the process of being
corrupted.
And the consequence of that was the end
of the world.
And so what that means is that if you
don't behave properly,
then you bring about the end of the
world and maybe you think,
well,
that's only the end of your world.
Fair enough.
Or maybe it's the only the end of your
family's world.
Know.
Which I suppose might give you some
pause,
but there's more to it than that because
you're connected to everyone else and
what you do that isn't good
distributes itself and all the things
you don't do that could be good take
away from the whole.
And so if you know that,
and I do think you know that if you take
it seriously,
because if you look at,
if you look at the historical events,
the cataclysmic events of the 20th
century,
seriously,
I do not think that you can fail to come
to that conclusion.
And Abraham journeyed going on still
towards the south.
That's interesting because to go south
means to go downhill to it's not good to
go south.
It's colloquial for going to where you
shouldn't go.
And so this is what happens to Abraham.
You know,
he,
his accent is preceded by a descent.
And that's very common in life I would
say.
And so it.
So the redemptive element of this
narrative is that if the covenant is
constructed properly,
so it's an arc,
which is your decision to align yourself
with God for all intents and purposes.
Then even the journey south can be part
of a broader journey upward and there
was a famine in the land.
That's mother nature failing to
cooperate.
I mean,
that's got to be pretty disheartening
for Abraham,
don't you think?
Because he finally gets it together when
he's 75 to leave and then you know,
because God says,
well,
let's get going and,
and so the first place he goes,
everyone's starving to death.
It's like,
you know,
you might think about that as a test of
faith,
wouldn't you say?
But he keeps going,
and then what happens?
Well,
he has to go to Egypt so great.
He goes,
where?
He's starving,
where everyone's starving,
and then to get away from where
everyone's starving,
he goes to a tyranny.
So the whole beginning of the story's
not particularly auspicious,
and Abraham went down into Egypt to
soldier in there for the famine was
grievous in the land.
It's a repetition of the same idea
again.
There's downhill voyage out into chaos,
right?
It's repeated over and over that the
beginning of Abraham's journey is
basically a secrets of,
of,
of experiences,
of exile,
chaos,
tyranny,
and catastrophe.
While you should be able to relate to
that,
you know how hard it is to get things
together.
You know,
you go out to do what you're supposed to
do,
say,
and there's your be set by the
intransigence of the world and failure.
Well,
so what are you supposed to do about
that?
Well,
maintain your faith in the good and
continuing to move forward.
That's the idea.
And part of that,
even if even if you don't buy the
metaphor,
it's like what are you going to do
instead?
That won't make it worse.
So even if there,
if it isn't an APP that you're pursuing
your at least for stalling the
transformation of the chaos into your,
of your life,
into sheer hell.
And that can certainly happen.
You know,
you see people who are having a terrible
time and then you see people who are
having a terrible time who were also
inhale and it's a lot better to just
have a terrible time than to have a
terrible time and be in hell at the same
time.
And it came to pass when he was come to
near to enter into Egypt that he said
unto [inaudible] wife,
behold,
now I know that thou art a fair woman to
look upon,
therefore it shall come to pass.
When the Egyptians cells see the,
that they shall say,
this is his wife and they will kill me,
but they will save the alive.
So look,
I mean Abraham,
Abraham is really having a rough time.
He's a failure,
right?
I mean,
he's wandering around through the land
of starvation.
Now he's going to go be a cause.
I slave in Egypt,
he has this incredibly attractive wife
and all he can look forward to is the
fact that the most successful man in
Egypt,
the Pharaoh will take her from him.
So he's got the whole embitterment thing
pretty much nailed down as far as I can
tell.
And this is when he makes one of his
errors,
let's say.
And one of the areas that humanizes him.
Say,
I pray thee that thou art my sister.
Then it may be well for me for my sake
and my soul shall live because of the.
And it to pass that when Abraham was
coming to Egypt,
the Egyptians beheld the woman that she
was very fair.
The prince is also a pharaoh saw her and
commended her before Pharaoh and the
woman was taken into Pharaoh's house and
he and treated Abraham well for her
sake.
And he had sheep and oxen and he asked
his men,
servants and maid servants she asses and
camels.
So actually things worked out pretty
well for,
for Abraham,
despite his deceit.
Right?
Which is quite interesting.
And I guess it's because if the
overarching structure is solid,
something like that,
it's something like that,
then then errors can still be forgiven
to,
to speak about it from a metaphorical
perspective.
And the Lord Plagued Pharaoh and his
house with great plagues because of
Sarah Abraham's wife.
While it doesn't seem very fair,
but because the pharaoh didn't know,
but,
but it's not the right way to look at it
the right way to look at it.
See,
there's a story later in the,
in the Bible about David and David.
David could be a pretty bad guy,
you know,
so one of the things he does is when he
becomes king,
he,
he's in his castle and he's looking over
the city and he sees a woman nude
bathing nude,
sunbathing nude on a,
on a,
on a roof out on the city,
and he's smitten by her,
floored by her,
and he has inquiries made about who she
is,
her name is Bathsheba,
and he finds out who her husband is and
her husband actually happens to be a
general in his army and he arranges for
that generally be put at the thick of
the battle and killed.
And then he takes Bathsheba.
So and,
and,
and the Lord is not pleased by that.
Let's put it that way.
And that's interesting.
You know,
it's an interesting story because you
might say,
well why can't the king do whatever the
hell he wants?
Like seriously,
he,
he's the king,
he's not.
And he's not like the prime minister or
the president,
right?
He,
he's the king.
And so you might say,
well,
why is the king subject to any rules
whatsoever?
What's the rationale for the king being
subject to rules?
Well,
the rationality emerges in these stories
is there are social strictures that are
such that even if the ruler of the land
transgresses against them,
there will be hell to pay and that's
continually presented over and over in
the biblical stories and it's a natural
law sort of ideas that there are.
There are intrinsic rules to the game of
social human being and if you and maybe
intrinsic rules to the to the natural
state of human being,
you break those rules consciously or
unconsciously at your absolute peril and
not only at your apparel but at the
peril of the state and it doesn't matter
who you are and so I would say this
actually an indication of God being fair
rather than being unfair because the
rule here is pharaoh or not.
You don't get to take someone else's
wife and the ignorance is no excuse.
Now you might say that's a little bit
harsh and perhaps it is a little bit
harsh,
but it's not without merit.
The idea is not without merit,
and of course Abraham is
complicit in this.
Despite that he is successful and
Farrell called Abraham and said,
what is this that thou has done unto me?
Why did so now tell me that she was very
wife?
Why said Thou you?
She is my sister.
I might've taken her to me to wife.
Now,
therefore,
behold thy wife take her and go thy way,
and Pharaoh commanded his men concerning
him and they sent them away and his wife
and all that he had and Abraham went out
of Egypt.
He and his wife and all that he had and
lot with him into the south.
And Abraham was very rich in cattle,
in silver and in gold.
And so what's interesting,
you know,
Abraham,
he,
he goes to the place of famine and then
he goes to the,
to this place of territory and then he,
he lies and then he almost loses his
wife,
but because he goes,
things work out for him and so hooray
for that.
And he went on his journeys from the
south.
Even the best.
I went to the place where his tent had
been at the beginning between Bethel and
high,
under the place of the altar.
So he makes another sacrifice which he
had made there at the first and there
Abraham called on the name of the Lord.
Well,
so he's had an adventure,
right?
He's,
he's,
he's finished his journey.
And,
and so there's a culminating point in
this narrative and now he doesn't know
what to do.
He's,
he's left the place,
he's out.
He doesn't know what to do.
So it's time to build an altar and make
a sacrifice and figure out and to ask
for divine guidance once again to figure
out,
okay,
well I'm done that been there,
done that.
What's next?
And the question is asked,
seriously,
and this is something to consider if you
want to know what to do,
ask seriously and say,
I'm willing to see Abraham sacrifices a
life to his vow.
Well,
so what do you do?
you don't sacrifice an animal.
You don't.
You don't make a blood sacrifice.
You do it psychologically.
You say,
I'm going to sacrifice my life to this
aim.
That's what you do.
If you're serious,
what do I do next?
Well,
I'm going to sacrifice my life to this
aim.
What is it that I should do that's worth
sacrificing my life too?
That's a serious question.
Well,
maybe that's the sort of question that
people don't ask because they're afraid
of the seriousness of the question and
the and the what,
the magnitude of the potential answer.
Do you really want to know what you
should do that would be worth
sacrificing your life too?
Well,
the answer is yes because it's worth it,
but the answer is also no because really
it's your life.
You know what?
If you're wrong and you're probably,
but maybe that doesn't matter,
maybe it doesn't matter because maybe
the rightness is in the process and not
in the naughty,
in the decision,
right?
Because it's not.
It's the beginning of a sequence of
decisions as we've already pointed out
unto the place of the altar which he had
made there at the first and there
Abraham called on the name of the Lord
and Lord also and lot also,
which went with Abraham.
Abraham had flocks and herds and tents,
and the land was not able to bear them
that they might dwell together for their
substance was great so that they could
not dwell together and there was a
strife between the herdman of Abram's
cattle.
The cowboys and the Herdman have
launched council and the Canaanite in
the parasite dwelled in the land.
Well,
and that's interesting too,
because you know,
Abrams having a pretty good time of it
now,
right?
He's out of starvation.
Hey,
that's good.
He's out of the tyranny now.
He's kind of wealthy and then the story
flips on him.
He's wealthy and now a bad thing happens
to them,
right?
It's got all this wealth and so does his
nephew and now they can't get along
because they have too much stuff.
So that's quite comical as well.
I think that's a comic interlude here.
Now they handle it properly and Abraham
said unto lot,
let there be no strife.
I pray thee between me and the in
between my herdman and I heard because
we're brothers is not the whole land
before the separate thyself.
I pray thee from me.
If you'll take the left,
then I'll take the right or if you
depart to the right,
then I'll go to the left.
So basically they sit down and say,
well,
you know,
one of us has got to get out of town and
it can be one or the other.
It doesn't really matter.
We can flip a coin here,
but we have to.
We have to separate.
And so they do it amicably and lot
lifted up his eyes and looked at all of
the plain of Jordan that it was well
watered everywhere.
So that's an intimation of Eden,
right?
Because you remember eating means well
watered place before the Lord destroyed
Sodom and Gomorrah,
even as the garden of the Lord,
like the land of Egypt.
As the outcome is done to soar.
So interesting.
You get four shout and we can hear
again,
right?
So lot and Abraham are making the
decision about where to go and and lot
looks out and sees a reasonable place,
but then this warning comes up that
there's a.
there's a city out there,
there's a place out there where things
are not going to go well.
Things are being done badly and things
Then lot chosen mold the plaintiff,
Jordan and lot journey the eastern,
they separated themselves.
The one from the other Abraham dwelled
in the land of Canaan in law dwell in
the cities of the plain and pitched his
tent towards Sodom,
but the men of Sodom were wicked and
sinners before the Lord exceedingly.
Now the word sin,
I've mentioned this to you before.
I think it's an interesting word.
It's.
It's the derivation of an archery term
in my understanding of its derivation
and it the Greek word was Hamartia and
Hamartia is an archery term,
which means to miss the Bullseye and you
think it's worth thinking about that
metaphorically because you've got to
think about all the ways that you could
miss the Bullseye,
right?
You close your eyes.
That's very common.
You could not lift up the damn bow and
Arrow to begin with.
You could face the wrong way.
You could be unskilled in your aim,
but I have and I also like the,
the,
the archery metaphor because human
beings are built on a hunting platform,
right?
And we always aim at things were things
that were were ballistic creatures on a
trajectory always,
and we're always aiming at something.
We're always aiming at the mark and
which is of course what you do when you
hunt,
right?
Because you have to hit the mark
precisely.
And that's what we're like.
And so what we're like that
psychologically we have to aim at
something and then move towards it.
And,
and so to sin is to miss the mark,
is to,
is to miss the Bullseye,
to fail,
to take aim,
to aim badly dame carelessly,
or to not aim at all.
And that says,
well,
that's,
that's like a sin of a mission.
That's to not do.
And then to be wicked is to aim at what
you know you shouldn't.
A mad.
And again,
I don't,
I don't think of that as an external
morality precisely.
I think that you can read the entire
biblical narrative again from a
psychological perspective and say,
we're not talking about external codes
of conduct here,
although we could.
We're not.
The wickedness that's being described is
the act of you doing something that you
know to be wrong,
period,
you know,
and you may do something you don't know
if it's wrong or not.
That isn't a sort of thing that we're
talking about and we're not talking
about the things that you do that are
right are there that other people think
are wrong.
We're not talking about those either.
We're talking about those things that
you consciously do,
although you know them to be wrong
yourself,
and that's the things that seem to get
people into the most trouble in these
stories and I believe that to be the
case.
I think that's very accurate.
Psychologically,
it's amazing because I see this all the
time.
If you do something wrong and because
you're ignorant,
you don't know better and it doesn't go
well for you,
that's the case,
but if you do something wrong and you
know it's wrong,
the punishment is is manifold and I
think the reason for that.
I think the reason for that is because
that makes you cane.
It means you betray your own ideal,
right?
If you just don't know,
well,
you haven't been trained,
your ideal,
you're just not together,
you maybe you're even willfully blind,
but if you do something you know to be
wrong,
then you've betrayed your own ideal and
that lands you.
Cain says to God,
once Kayden destroys able,
he says,
I cannot bear my punishment,
and the Lord said unto Abraham,
after that lot was separated from lift
up,
now look upward and look from the place
where they'll are northward and
southward and eastward and westward for
all the land which thou seest to thee.
I will give it and the seed forever,
and then we'll make those seat as the
dust of the earth so that if a man can
number the dust of the earth than shell,
all thy seed be numbered.
Arise,
walk through the land and the length of
it and the breadth of it for I will give
it unto thee
in the Cathedral.
At short,
I can't say that properly because my
French is nonexistent.
So a cathedral is a cross and that
transformation takes place at the crux
of the cross,
which is exactly right because the the
transformation takes place at the point
of maximal suffering and the cathedral
is designed to indicate that right
symbolically.
Now
what happens in a religious ceremony is
also a journey and it's a journey in
some senses to the holy city,
and then that's also played out in the
idea of pilgrimage,
right?
Because you go to the holy city,
actually,
you go to Jerusalem or wherever it is
that you think the holy city is.
You go there and that takes you out of
your country and away from your kid and
away from your family into the strange
land.
And as you make the journey,
you transform and when you come back,
you're not the same.
That's the Hobbit,
right?
That's the story of the hobbit.
But let's say you can't afford to go on
a pilgrimage.
So you go to the cathedral at chart and
there's a huge maze on the ground and
it's the world north,
west,
south and east,
just as God describes here.
So it's laid out and you enter the maize
at one side and in the middle is a stone
pattern that looks like a flower and
it's.
It's the place where being wells fourth
and it's at the center of the Cathedral,
and what that means is that if you
accept your suffering,
then you move to the place where the
spirit of being wells fourth,
that's what that means,
and so you enter the the maze and you
walk and it's divided into quadrants and
you walk one quadrant completely and
then the main pathway takes you into the
next quadrant and you walked that
completely and then it takes you to the
third one and the fourth one.
And then when you walk the maze
completely everywhere.
When you've gone everywhere in the
world,
north,
south,
east and west,
where you've.
When you've traversed the territory
completely,
then you come to the center and then
it's yours.
And that's what this is.
So I've noticed when I've been
renovating houses,
I'd like to do that.
I paid a lot of attention to the
psychological process of house
renovation because I learned from young
that you said this,
this is something man.
He said because he was.
He was talking about the stages of
integration,
psychological integration,
and he looked beyond piaget.
I would say,
um,
although piaget looked very far,
he said,
here,
here's a conjunction.
You have to get your rationality on your
emotion together.
That's a male,
female conjunction,
symbolically speaking,
male rationality,
female emotionality.
You want to bring those together so that
they're oriented in the same direction.
Your emotions in your rationale will be
served the same purpose,
so then you're unified in mind and
spirit,
let's say,
but that's sort of good enough.
Once you've got that together,
then there's a boat.
You have a body,
and then that's
a male female conjunction again,
a divine conjunction,
the recreation of Adam before his
division into female and male,
and the reconstruction of the
androgynous Christ that all that,
all those ideas are linked together.
So now you have your emotion and your
rationality moving in the same
direction,
but you're not acting it out.
So now you have to unite that abstract
part of you with your body and start
acting out what you think and feel,
and that's the next conjunction,
but it's not the last one.
The last conjunction is when you realize
that there is no distinction between you
and your experience there the same thing
and so then when you put together your
house,
you're putting together yourself.
So I've noticed when I've lived in
places rented or owned,
didn't matter.
Then if there were part of the place,
if there was a part of the place that I
hadn't attended to,
whatever that might mean,
it might meant cleaned.
It might've meant fixed,
but it certainly meant at least
thoroughly investigated.
Then that was chaos.
It was like it was.
It was like the desert.
That part that's,
that's a way of thinking about it.
It wasn't mine.
Even if I owned it wasn't mine.
I had to interact with it before it
became mine and I had to interact with
it and I had to put it in order and then
it became mine and then.
And then to the degree that it became
mine and was in order,
then I was also put an order.
Now you know that because you go into
places that make you uncomfortable and
maybe it's your own house,
it's highly probable.
It's highly probable.
I,
you know,
I walk into,
well Chinese doctors do this.
Traditional Chinese doctors,
they go into place people's place and
they diagnosed their health conditions
on the,
on the balance of Yin and Yang chaos and
order.
They walk into a house that this is easy
to do.
You walk into a house,
there's too much chaos.
Hey,
you can detect that in no time flat.
Everything is out of order and chaotic.
You don't even want to be there.
You certainly don't want to open the
refrigerator.
That's for sure.
And there are things that should've been
done years ago,
everywhere.
And every one of those things is a fight
that hasn't happened and something
that's been avoided.
And you can't even walk in there and
maintain your health.
As soon as you walk in there,
you're sicker than you were when you
were outside.
And that's one sort of place.
And then another sort of places you go
in and you look at the living room and
the person has vacuum the living room
rug and the lines that were vacuumed are
parallel to one another and the and the
furniture is covered with plastic and
you get a glass of water and then just
as you're going to set it down on the
coffee table,
the person rushes over and puts a
coaster underneath it and everything in
that house says to you that it would be
a lot more perfect in that house if you
were either not there or dad and that's.
And that's the message that the whole
house is blasting at you.
And if you happen to live there,
then you're going to be sick and what
you're going to be sick from is too much
order.
And in the other house you're going to
be sick from too much chaos.
And so when you interact with the house,
the unexplored parts are the chaos that
had the parts that you have not yet
contended with are the chaos that has
not yet been transformed by your
embodied logos.
Action into habitable territory.
And it does not belong to you.
Arise,
walk through the land in the length of
it and the breadth of it,
for I will give it unto thee,
the neighbor and removed his tent and
came and dwelt in the plaintiff camera
which is in Hebrew and in built there an
altar unto the Lord.
And it came to pass in the days of
[inaudible],
King of Shinar,
Arioch,
King of Lsr cheered a little more.
There's a lot of kings,
we won't talk about them.
These made war with Barrett,
King of Sodom,
and with Burger King of Gomorrah,
she nap king of Admah and the king of
Bela,
which is your.
And these were joined together in the
veil of system,
which is the salt sea [inaudible].
Now,
this is actually very much relevant
today because you see the veil of see
them,
which is the salt sea is the farthest
south you can go if south is down
because it's the Dead Sea and the Dead
Sea is the lowest place that there is.
So what's happened is that there's chaos
in the lowest place that there is.
That's what this story says.
And what happens to Lord as he gets
tangled up in the chaos of the lowest
place that there is,
and in the 14th year came chedorlaomer
and the kings that were with him and
smote the Ref fames and asteroid name,
and the zooms and Hammond,
the eminence and Chava Korea,
Korea theme and the whites in their
mount sire onto elpar in which is by the
wilderness.
And they returned and came to end
Mishpat,
which has Kadesh and smote all the
country.
The male acolytes,
amalekites,
and the amorites that dwelt in has a has
is zoned to my.
Hey.
Hey has azonto mark.
There we go perhaps and their window
with the King of Sodom and the king of
Gomorrah,
and the king of Admah and the king of
Babylon,
and the king of Bela.
The same as Zara.
And they joined,
battled with them in the veil of sodium.
So this is absolute chaos and mayhem in
the lowest place.
It's hell essentially
with Cheddar,
a little more of the king of a lamb and
with title of King,
of Nations.
And Amarillo fail.
King of Shinar and area king of Ella's
or four kings with five and the veil of
system was full of slime pits.
Low inhale like with war isn't enough.
They had to throw the slime pits in
there.
Apparently around the Dead Sea.
There are pits of a bite bitumen like
the like the tar pits in near La and so
that this seems to actually be
historically accurate and the kings of
Sodom and Gomorrah fled and fell there
and they've remained,
fled to the mountain and they took their
goods and they took all the goods of
Sodom and Gomorrah and all their
victuals and went their way and they
took lot.
Abram's brother's son who dwelt in Sodom
and his in departed.
So Abraham has a family member who falls
into the lowest place and there came one
that had escaped and told Abraham the
Hebrew for he dwelt in the plaintiff or
the amorite brother of his goal.
And brother vainer.
And these were confederate with Abraham.
And when Abraham heard that his brother
was taken captive.
He armed his trained servants,
born in his own house,
318,
and pursued them on to Dan.
Well,
so now we also know that Abraham is a
pretty brave guy,
right?
He gets word that this horrible war has
broken out in the worst of all possible
places and that his nephew is involved
in the first thing he does.
His mountaintop is posy and get the hell
in there and rescue his nephew.
So Abraham's no,
whatever goodness is from the Old
Testament perspective,
it isn't harmlessness,
right?
It isn't emasculation and castration.
It's not that it's not weakness,
it's not the inability to fight,
none of that is associated with virtue.
It's the sort of strength and enable
someone to mountain arm team of 300
people when he finds out that his nephew
is being kidnapped in a terrible war and
to get the hell out there and take them
back.
And so that's,
that's a,
that's a call to two.
It's a coal to power that not,
not a kind of peaceful meekness.
That's funny too,
because you know there's a line in the
new testament,
the meek shall inherit the earth.
I've got to look at my phone for a sec
here because I don't know what time it
is.
There's a line in the new testament that
says it's in the sermon on the mount,
says the meek shall inherit the earth,
and that I read that line always
bothered me.
I thought,
no way.
That's not that.
That's not right.
Knee can't be the right word.
So when I was doing the story of Noah
and talking about the sermon on the
mount,
I spent a bunch of time looking at
commentaries on that line,
looking at the roots,
the,
you know,
the Greek roots in the Hebrew roots and
trying to figure out what that meant and
it meat does not mean meek.
That's wrong.
Here's what it means.
Those who have weapons and know how to
use them,
but still keep the machine will inherit
the earth.
Jesus,
that's a lot different,
man.
It's a lot better,
right?
Because the way it's normally knits,
normally interpreted is if you're so
weak that your harmless,
then things will go well for you.
It's like,
no,
that's not right.
That's and that's not.
That can't be right.
It doesn't fit with the narrative is
certainly doesn't fit with this
narrative and he divided himself against
them.
He and his servants by night and smoke
them and pursued them into Hobart,
which is on the left side of Damascus
and he brought back all the goods and
his brother lot and his goods and the
women also ended the people.
Good work.
Abraham and the kings of Sodom went out
to meet him after his return at the
slaughter of Charitable Omer and of the
kings that there were there with him at
the Valley of [inaudible],
which is the king.
Stale and Melchizedek King of Salem
brought forth bread and wine and he was
the priest of the most high God.
And he blessed him and said,
blessed be Abraham of the Most High God,
possessor of heaven and earth,
and blessed be the most high God which
has delivered
thine enemies into thy hand and gave him
tithes of all.
And the King of Sodom said to Abraham,
give me the person's intake diet goods
to myself,
that the goods that Abraham Abraham
rescued right out of the kinks.
And Abraham said to the King of Sodom,
I have lift up my hand unto the Lord.
What does that mean?
It means I've made a vow.
That's what it means.
That that's what that phrase means.
I've made a vow to God,
the possessor of heaven and earth,
that I will not take anything from a
thread even to a shoelace.
I won't take anything that's yours.
Less you should say,
I've made a broom.
Rich.
I'll take only that which my young men
have eaten and the portion of men that
went with me and Aner Eshkol and let
them take their portion.
And so Abraham decides here he's,
he's made this immense sacrifice and in
and done this incredibly brave act and
rescued his nephew.
And rescued the king's goods and they
offer him a reward and he says,
I'm not going to take the reward.
And the reason for that is that he
doesn't want to contaminate the,
the,
the ethical,
purity of his actions.
He doesn't want to be paid.
He doesn't want it.
He doesn't want to benefit from doing.
He doesn't want to have.
What is it exactly.
He doesn't want to benefit
inappropriately from doing the right
thing.
It's something like that.
And so it's another testament to his
character in a very complex testament,
right?
Because he's not a CEO.
He's not a good man in any simple sense.
I mean,
look what's just happened.
He's,
he's mounted and armed.
He's mounted in armed.
Uh,
he,
he's,
he's led an army into battle and park
and,
and participated in a slaughter.
He refuses to benefit from it except to
get back.
What was his.
That's it.
He refuses to benefit from it except to
get back what was rightfully his.
And in that way,
he maintains his covenant with God
even to a shoe latchet I anything don't
ever so smaller mean less dao should
claim a share with God and the honor due
to him.
This is from Matthew Pool,
who was an English nonconformists
theologian commenting on that line even
to a shoe latchet.
Anything they'll never saw,
meaner,
small,
lest thou should claim a share with God.
And the honor due to him to his blessing
alone,
I do.
And I will own my riches or less,
thou should say,
Abraham is enriched with my spoils.
And however he pretended kindness and
charity,
yet indeed it was his covetousness that
put them upon this work.
After these things,
the word of the Lord came unto Abraham
and division saying,
fear not Abraham.
I'm a shield and die exceedingly.
I exceeding great reward the vision
issue again.
Well,
we went through that last week.
Fear Not Abraham,
I am Thy Shield and thy exceeding great
reward.
And Abraham said,
Lord God,
what can you give me?
Seeing as I'm childless tagless?
And that's the only thing that matters
table at this point,
and the steward of my house is this is
easier of Dem Damascus,
no kin,
and Abraham said,
Abraham said,
behold to me,
thou has given no seed,
and Lo one born in my house is mine.
Air and behold,
the word of the Lord came unto him
saying,
this shall not be there in heir,
but he that shall come forth out of
known bottle should be nine here.
So he gets promised the impossible once
again,
and he brought him forth abroad and
said,
now look towards the heaven and tell the
stars if that will be able to number
them.
And he said unto him,
so shall thy seed be,
and he believed in the Lord and he
counted to him for righteousness.
Seeing that this,
this,
this is the covenant idea,
this belief,
because here's the belief.
It's the willingness to act as if the
world is constructed so that if you do
the right thing,
the best possible outcome will occur.
It's a decision.
That's the covenant,
right?
It's a decision about how to live in the
world because the evidence can't be
there before you make the decision.
Right,
and so you might hedge your bets,
you know when,
when Christ comes back in the book of
revelation to judge people because he
comes back as a judge and virtually
everyone gets cast out with the chaff
and not saved with the wheat and he,
he says something very interesting.
He appears in the vision with a sword
coming out of his mouth.
It's a horrifying vision and he divides
the.
He divides humanity into the damned,
in the safe or the day.
Yes,
the damned and the saved.
He says something very interesting.
He says
to those who were neither hot nor cold,
I will spew you out of my mouth.
And,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a disgust metaphor,
right?
T?
And what it says is that the worst
punishment isn't waiting for those who
committed to something and did wrong.
The worst punishment is reserved for
those who committed to nothing and
stayed on the fence.
And that's really something to.
That's really something to think about
it.
And it's also something that I believe
to be true because I see that stacy,
this is
utterly destructive because there's no
progress.
All the resist movement backwards,
there's aging and suffering and no
progress,
and so to not commit to anything is the
worst of all.
Transgressions to commit means to put
your body and soul into something.
To offer your life as a sacrifice means
that you're willing to make a bargain
with fate and the bargain is I'm going
to act as if if I give it my all,
then the best possible thing will happen
because of that and to to not see the
analogy between that and the act of
faith in God is to misunderstand the
completely.
And it has to be an act of faith because
how are you going to know?
You can look at other people,
but that isn't going to do it.
It's Kierkegaard was very clear about
this sort of thing.
There's certain sorts of truths that you
can only learn for yourself through
experience.
And that's of course why Abraham also
has to go out alone,
right?
He has to leave this candidates.
It's an individual.
It's the individuation process like
dying.
It's something that you do alone.
There's no way you can tell what is
within your grasp,
let's say,
unless you make the ultimate sacrifice
and there's no way of finding out
without actually making it,
and so that's the sacrificial act,
right?
That's,
that's really emphasized in the active
Abraham
being called upon to sacrifice Isaac.
You think about that is Abraham,
he's been doing.
He's been like breaking himself into
pieces,
trying to progress forward through
starvation and tyranny and war and
deceit and the potential loss of his
wife and childlessness and like
everything that can really be following
you in some sense.
And finally God grants them.
Isaac,
when he's old,
it's impossible.
He gets Isaac,
his son,
and then what does he do next is say,
well,
you know,
that son that you've been waiting for.
So for so long it's like,
I'd like to see just exactly what you're
made of.
So I think you should offer him up as a
sacrifice.
And I mean it's a very barbaric story in
a sense,
and maybe in more than just the sense,
but Abraham does maintain his covenant.
He's willing to make the sacrifice he's
willing to make.
This is the thing he's willing to make
whatever sacrifices necessary to keep
his covenant with God intact,
and that's that,
and that's the decision.
Well,
maybe it's no surprise that people don't
do that,
and he believed in the Lord and he
counted it to him for righteousness and
he said unto him,
I am the Lord that brought the out of Ur
of the Chaldees to give this land to you
to inherit it.
And he said,
Lord God,
whereby shall I know that I show
inherited?
And he said to him,
this is a sacrificial story.
Again,
take an F.
I have for three years and a goat of
three years in a realm of three years in
a turtle.
Dove and a young pigeon is fairly
specific actually,
and he took all of these and divided
them and laid each piece one against
another,
but the birds divided,
he not.
Now there's a reason for that and I
don't know the reason for it.
And when the walls came down upon the
carcasses,
Abraham drove them away and when the sun
was going down,
a deep sleep fell upon Abraham and low,
a horror of great darkness fell upon him
had didn't mean he was afraid of the
dark,
which is what I thought it meant when I
first read it.
It isn't what it means.
It means that he fell into a trance or
something like that.
And then he was enveloped by absolute
horror.
So that's how this story begins.
And here's the commentary from Joseph
Benson who was an English methodist
minister who lived in 17,
49,
was born in 17,
and the sun was going down about the
time of the evening,
evening ablation,
the washing for he abode by them praying
and waiting till toward evening a deep
sleep fell upon Abraham.
Well,
this was not a common sleep through
weariness or carelessness.
Don't know what a sloop is that's
supposed to be asleep.
Not a common sleep through weariness or
Carolyn carelessness,
but a divine ecstasy that being wholly
taken off from things sensible,
he might be wholly taken up with the
contemplation of things spiritual well,
it really makes you wonder what Abraham
was up to in his campsite,
so
he was participating in something that
enabled this experience and low or a
horror of great darkness fell upon him.
This was designed to strike all upon the
spirit of Abraham and to possess them
with a holy reverence.
Holy fear prepares the soul for holy
joy.
God humbles first and then lifts up
echoes of Psychedelic Experience,
and he said unto Abraham,
no of assurity that thy seed shall be a
stranger in a land that is not theirs
and she'll serve them and they shall
afflict them 400 years and also that
nation whom they shall serve.
I will judge and afterwards shall they
come out with great substance and now
shall go to vi.
Fathers in peace,
thou shalt be buried in the good old
age,
but in the fourth generation,
they shall come hither again.
For the inequity of the Amorites is not
yet full
commentaries of Joseph Benson.
Once again,
they shall come hither again.
Hither to the land of Canaan.
We're in vow note art.
Now art.
The reason why they must not have the
land of promise in possession until the
fourth generation is because the
iniquity of the amorites was not yet
full.
The righteous God has determined that
the Amorites shall not be cut off until
they arrived at such a pitch of
wickedness and therefore till it come to
that the seed of Abraham must be kept
out of possession.
So the interpretation of the story
essentially is that Abraham's
descendants will end up in slave in
Egypt for a long,
lengthy period of time and eventually
come back to the land of Canaan.
And it's interesting too because this is
part of Abram's bargain with God and in
this divine vision.
I mean,
he's been promised everything,
but it's a pretty tough bargain because
you know when,
when,
when God is pushed or reveals himself,
let's say,
he says,
look,
you're going to get your damn
descendants.
You know,
but it's not going to be our.
It's,
it's,
it's going to be a tough journey.
They're going to be slaves and slave for
a very long time and eventually come
back and you won't see it.
You'll be dead long before then.
And so it's a realistic promise in a
sense.
And you might say,
well,
Abraham is so dated,
desperate to keep the faith that he's
willing to read good into what isn't
good.
But I think,
I think,
I don't think that's the right way to
look at it.
I think the right way to look at it is
the people who wrote these stories for
very realistic and they knew that even
if things turned out well for you,
I mean it was still going to be real.
You know,
it wasn't going to be some fantasy.
It's like,
let's say you have a family that
flourishes.
People are still going to die,
there's still going to get sick,
they're still gonna have,
they're still going to be alive,
you know,
with all of it's suffering,
but it'll be,
but it'll be a life that's rich enough
and complete enough so that it'll
justify its,
its nature essentially.
And so,
and it came to pass that when the sun
went down and it was dark,
behold a smoking furnace and a burning
lamp that passed between the pieces.
Albert Barnes,
American theologian commented on this,
the oven of smoke and lamp of flame
symbolize the smoke of destruction in
the light of salvation,
they're passing,
passing through the pieces of the
sacrificial victims,
and probably consuming the mess and
accepted sacrifice,
or the ratification of the Covenant on
the part of God as the dividing and
presenting of them were on the part of
Abraham.
In the same day,
the Lord made a covenant with Abraham
saying unto thy seed,
I haven't given this land from the river
of Egypt unto the great river,
the River Euphrates,
the Canaanites and the Kennedys sites
and the cadman nights,
et cetera.
Now Cri.
Abram's wife bear him,
no children.
And she had a handmade.
Wait a second.
I think we'll stop there.
I'm tiring out.
And it's just.
And it's 9:29.
So that's a very good place to stop.
So yes.
Thank you.
So I should,
I should close properly and just sum up.
So what happens here is that that
Abraham enters into a covenant with God
to act in the world,
and the action is an adventure story
essentially,
and the adventures repeat and their and
their punctuated by success and sat and
sacrifice and re contemplation.
Right?
And it's so.
It's this,
it's this journey.
It's the,
it's the hero's journey uphill.
I'm here,
there's a crisis.
I collapsed,
I reconstruct myself to a higher place,
and life is like that continually.
And that's the story of Abraham and
that's all contained though.
It's all contained and this is the thing
that's so cool because that is what your
life is going to be like.
Whether you plan out your life or not,
it's going to be punctuated like that.
Maybe it won't go up,
maybe it'll go down.
And the question is,
what sort of container do you need to be
in in order to tolerate the movement up
and down?
And that's what the story of Abraham
provides.
It provides a,
it provides a description of the
covenant that's like the Ark of the
covenant and the Ark or the same thing,
right?
Except the covenant is the psychological
equivalent of the Ark of the covenant is
have faith in the structure of existence
and go forth.
That's the covenant and that and this
story is,
that's the best possible solution that
you have at hand.
Alright,
so I'm going to make a request with
regards to the questions which may mean
have to reorient yourself in the line.
I would like the first two questions on
each side if possible to relate
specifically to tonight's lecture and
then I can and then I can address more
general issues if that's,
if that's okay.
So,
and I again,
I would like you to carefully speak into
the mic so that the people who are
watching can hear.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
I can.
The story about Abraham saying his wife
was his sister.
You referred to that as him making a
mistake.
I'm not quite sure I understand how
you're reading that does a mistake
seeing as it was a very deliberate
decision and it had a pretty good
outcome for him and he does the same
thing a few chapters later.
Yes.
This is true.
You see,
I don't,
I don't feel that I've cracked out part
of that story properly.
Now,
the reason I said it was a mistake is
because it's clearly an act of deceit
and it and it,
and it does put the Pharaoh in a very
awkward position.
Not to mention survived by the way,
or how do you say that?
I don't know how to say that.
Surrey,
Surrey.
It's sariah to begin with.
Yes.
Is that right?
Surgery?
Yes.
Okay.
And then it's Sarah and Abraham means
high king,
something like that.
And Abraham means father of the people
in Surrey means Princess and Sarah means
mother of the people.
It's some,
I haven't exactly right.
I'll tell you next week,
but that's part of the name
transformation,
the,
it seems to me that at least in part
it's an indication of Abraham Abraham's
willingness to use a sub optimal
solution when driven to it by necessity.
I don't think it's a heroic act to
pretend that your wife is your sister.
Now you know,
and,
and maybe you might say,
well,
under the circumstances there was
nothing else he could have done,
but it does seem it.
I can't see how you can interpret it
other than as a departure from the
truth,
but I know that that's not all there is
to it and it does seem to work out well
for him and my interpretation is that,
well,
if you're oriented properly in the
world,
the grace of God allows you a few
necessary mistakes,
something like that.
Do you have an alternative idea?
Well why not?
What is it about that,
that that means it because it's Abraham
and it isn't reasonable to attribute
mistakes to him or what is it?
Because at least I think it says in the
text that he's looking to get out of a
bad situation and he does whatever is
the best thing that's available to him
and not dimension.
As I said,
he does the same trick a few chapters
later.
Yeah,
well maybe.
Maybe it is the case that,
you know,
it's like a white lie issue.
You know,
you say,
well there's a white lie.
Acceptable.
I would say,
well,
the best that you can come up with is
acceptable.
That that doesn't mean it's.
It's optimal though,
right?
Like all right,
I'll give you a foolish example because
it's the best that I could do at the
moment,
but know if you.
If you have a loved one who says,
does this dress make me look fat?
The answer to that question is I don't
answer questions like that.
That's the answer,
right?
Because the other answer is the white
lie.
That would mean at least in this
context,
and that means that on the one hand
you're maintaining the positive contract
between you and the person who's asking
the question,
but then you're still sacrificing the
truth within that.
So you're,
you're,
you're maintaining your relationship
with the higher order truth but
sacrificing a lower order truth and,
and that would be better than the
reverse,
but it's not as good as not sacrificing
the truth at all.
And I would say that if you're maybe
fortunate because sometimes it's a
matter because you can be in a situation
where all your choices are bad.
I've seen people in situations like
that.
I've probably been in situations like
that and maybe that is what's happening
in that story is every choice,
Abraham is in front of him is bad,
but I can't help but think that it's
more than that.
It means that if you're doing the best
you can and it's not perfect,
it can still be good enough.
That's how it looks to me.
Thank you.
Hello Dr Peterson,
you mentioned earlier there's been a
pervasive problem of nihilism and moral
relativism,
uh,
and that,
that can kind of be cured with a novice,
naive optimism that's grounded in fact,
and what can actually be done to improve
situations.
Is there a way to communicate that
message to a younger audience?
They teenagers in high school
environment,
which is nowadays a hotbed for this kind
of nihilistic,
morally relativist thinking.
Great.
I'm glad you asked that.
So I'm going to tell you,
I was thinking about saying this at the
beginning,
but I decided not to,
but now I get to say it because I got
this question.
So that's so cool.
Um,
I have plans and so plan number one,
I have worked with some people to design
a website that will enable high
university students to enter their
course descriptions,
their professor's name,
the subdiscipline,
and the university and an artificial
intelligence agent will tell them if the
course is postmodern,
neo,
Marxist indoctrination.
No,
not only,
and I have made tentative arrangements
with someone to finance a advertising
campaign for that site.
And so the goal is well to inform the
consumer,
do you want to be educated or do you
want to be?
And happily you'll build,
use the site equally for both purposes,
right?
Because if you want,
if you want to take the,
the,
the courses that I would regard as
indoctrination,
then this will give you a way of
ensuring that nothing that you get
exposed to won't be of that sort.
So,
and then I'm going to make a video to
introduce that to university students
and their parents and I'm going to
outline what I think the universities
are doing wrong.
There's about 20 things they're doing
wrong and they're seriously wrong
things.
And I'm going to start by describing the
utility of a university education in
humanities education because the
humanities education makes you into the
kind of autonomous individual that can
go away from,
that can be independent and can
communicate and think,
and that has immense economic value,
right?
Not,
not just spiritual value and cultural
value,
but economic value.
And so there's,
I don't want to tell people not to go to
university,
I want to tell them to go to university
and grow the hell up and learn to
communicate and think and I want them to
avoid the people who will take the
spirit away from them.
And so that's what that website is going
to do,
I hope.
And the goal is to drop the enrollment
in the indoctrination courses across the
English speaking world by 75 percent
within five years.
That's the goal.
And then you ask that,
you ask more specifically about high
school students.
Well,
we have this future authoring program
that has been used for university
students and it produces about a 30
percent improvement in retention.
And we've tested several thousand
university students.
Anyone can use it by the way,
it's not for university students,
but it was easy for us to test its
beneficial impact.
Even if people only spend under 90
minutes on it,
it still has approximately that effect,
especially on young men,
especially if they're ethnic minorities,
especially if they're not oriented
towards a career and didn't do very well
in school and so that's really cool
because it's really hard to design a
psychological intervention that helps
the people who are doing the worst,
most psychological intervention.
So imagine there are people who are
doing not so well and people who are
doing well and you produce a
psychological intervention.
What usually happens is the people who
are doing well benefit even more.
Right,
but this seems to work for the
disenfranchised.
So we're thrilled about that really.
And so we produced a version for high
school students.
Yes.
And so,
but we don't have them look three to
five years out into the future because
they can't and they don't know enough.
You know,
it's hard for full,
full,
fully mature adults to look that far
into the future.
High school kids can probably manage
three to six months and so we're going
to have them concentrated on character
development and and what they want for
their from their friendships and how
they would like orient themselves in
school and to start thinking about the
sorts of person that they would like to
be and that never happens in schools.
Weirdly enough.
There's a guy named John Gatto who won
the teacher of the year award in New
York City and then in New York state and
then it stopped being a teacher.
By the way.
He wrote a series of books about the
education system that explain why
students in pre university education
aren't taught to be autonomous
individuals.
It's very interesting what he's
discovered historically,
but anyways,
we're going to market that probably two
parents and two university students
themselves rather than to the schools
because our experience has been that
producing this sort of material directly
for individuals works much better.
It's much more efficient and so then
students will be able to,
or their parents will be able to
purchase the program and the students
will be able to use it to design their
own personality in a manner that would
make them thrilled to be alive.
Let's say that would be the goal,
right?
Yes.
I'm going to get you to turn it to put
it down a little more either.
Excellent.
Perfect.
Yes,
yes.
And I,
I think,
um,
especially the literature in
Developmental Psychology,
I think bears this out,
but I think a huge part of learning is
interaction and discourse and that seems
very difficult in an online setting,
even if it's through text.
I don't,
I don't quite see it as the same thing.
And additionally I think there's a huge
motivational factor that's a difficult
to.
It's difficult to keep motivated when
you're isolated and nobody else around
us pursuing the same goal.
So how would you dress?
You're absolutely right on both counts.
I would say that the idea of an online
humanities university is grandiose and
it may not be possible.
And the reason for that is that,
and as you're alluding to,
we actually don't understand what the
university is.
We think it's lectures and exams,
but it's probably not.
It's certainly being together with
people of your own age.
As you start your life,
it's moving away from your household.
It's establishing yourself as a credible
intellect,
right?
It's,
it's picking a new group of peers.
It's all of those things and it isn't
clear how that can be replicated online.
Now.
The people that I'm talking to are
sophisticated enough to understand
Marshall McLuhan's dictum that the
medium is the message and so I think it
would be a mistake to attempt to
duplicate the university online because
you can't.
But so what we're concentrating on right
now is not so much content but
infrastructure.
The question is we want to set up an egg
and a system of education online that
will be autonomously self-governing and
self improving and the content in some
sense,
we're not so much interested in the
content as we are interested in the
process by which people who generate
good content might be optimally
rewarded.
And that's what we want to get,
right.
And that's probably a discussion that
will take a year or two years to flesh
out.
We started to conceptualize what the
system might look like,
but,
but to your point,
it isn't.
We're not taking lectures and putting
them online,
although obviously that's what I'm doing
that,
that isn't going to make an online
humanities university and we know that
and I think everything you said is,
is,
is very accurate and also indicative of
the high probability that something like
this would fail.
So,
but you know,
we're,
we're going to try to be aware of the
pitfalls.
We're also going to.
I read this great book,
I would recommend this book.
It's,
it's a very funny book by a guy named
John Gaul.
It's called system antics and it's a
cult classic system antics.
And it's about how systems really work
and how they fail.
And it's a work of ironic comedy,
but it's quite brilliant.
And one of the things,
one line he,
it's,
it's made of a bunch of axioms.
And here's one axiom I just love.
This is the system does not do what it's
name says it does,
and so I worked in Alberta social
services when I was a kid about 18 or so
and I worked as a consultant and I I
wanted and I got involved in projects
that were above my pay grade,
I would say,
and I learned a lot about how how large
bureaucracies functioned and I was asked
at one point to update a report that had
been made the year before about what
percentage of the spending of the social
services department actually went to the
recipients of welfare and social aid in
general.
And the answer was the system did not
know and could not find out.
And they had hired a very expensive
consulting firms to answer that question
the year before and I was asked to
update it,
which was quite odd to begin with.
But then I did.
I went and looked at the consulting
report and I went into the data and what
I found was that none of it was real,
but even more importantly,
there was no way of knowing whether it
was true or false.
Because the system had never been set up
to calculate what percentage of its
total spending actually went to the
recipients of social aid.
It just blew me away.
And then I thought,
and I was reading this book at the same
time and I thought,
oh,
the purpose of the social services
department is to employ people in the
social services department.
And I mean I wasn't being cynical about
that.
It's like charity.
Most charities,
you know,
it's like 90 percent overhead.
So what does the charity do?
It runs itself now.
You don't want to be cynical about that
because big businesses are the same and
most like even if they're running at a
profit,
the profit is like five percent.
So the business spends 95 percent of its
time maintaining itself,
you know?
And it makes a bit of product and it
makes a bit of profit.
But most of what it does is maintain
itself.
So anyways,
one of the axioms in that book that was
one of them is the system does not do
what it says it does.
So that's [inaudible].
Then you can face the system with a
clear head.
And say,
okay,
well this thing isn't doing what it says
it's doing,
but it's probably doing something and
the thing is doing might be useful,
but we should figure out what that thing
is.
So that's been really useful to me as a
guide to thinking.
But the other thing he said was if you
want to build a big system that works,
start with by building a small system
that works and scale it,
and we've done that.
For example,
with the self authoring programs,
you know,
is built small scale systems that are
very robust with the hope that they'll
scale.
And that's the same.
We'll do the same thing here is start
with a small amount of content.
See if we can reward.
See,
what I would like to have happened is,
you know,
there's a lot of people out there who
are pretty intensely educated and some
of them are really creative and so
imagine that there's a timeline.
Imagine you could do a humanities.
As you imagine there's a timeline say of
a thousand years that's scalable.
Then imagine that,
that there would be lectures associated
with the timeline at different levels of
resolution,
so we might call for a lecture on this.
The third century had what happened in
the third century.
80.
You've got half an hour to explain it.
You can explain it any way you want.
You can use animation,
you can use lecture,
you can use text,
you can make a movie.
We don't care.
What you have to do is that's the topic.
That's the time span.
That's the amount of time and then you
can post it and so we could generate
content that way and let people
experiment and then we can have people
review the content as part of their
education,
generate questions about the content as
part of their assignments,
rate the questions as part of their
assignments and rate the content,
and then if we charged people,
imagine you had to pay $50 a month to
enroll,
something like that.
Maybe we would allow you when you first
enroll,
maybe you get to use $5 of it as
disposable income.
You can award that to any creator you
want,
but as you progress through the courses,
you're right to determine where your
money goes would increase as you became
more and more educated.
Hopefully that way we would get some
quality control built into it.
So those are some of the ideas that
were,
that were starting to play around with.
So that's the only one I'm considered.
Modista motivation.
What's that?
The motivation issue for individuals?
Well,
I'm not going to go into that because it
would take too long,
but,
but rest assured that we are thinking
about that very hard as well.
We're going to build competition into
it.
We're going to build cooperation into
We hope to build peer interrelationships
into it.
I all that's possible but,
but complex,
right?
Because it's.
We don't know how to build an online
education system really.
And,
but it would be fun to experiment and
see if we can figure out how to do it.
So thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
so I,
I couldn't really zero in on any
particular question.
So it's more of a family questions that
I have about the nature and cultivation
of conscience,
which was in a sense of what the story a
exemplified about Abraham.
What,
why do you
say that?
Why do you think that the story
exemplified the development of conscious
of conscience specific specifically?
Well,
going back to the Zig Zag,
right?
And the star.
How you have to keep.
Okay.
So that's what you were referring to.
Orienting yourself completely
autonomously on your own terms.
Right.
A toe.
See,
okay.
So you,
you hit on some great there.
I think,
you know,
this is something weirdly enough that I
learned most particularly from the
Pinocchio Movie,
which I spent a lot of time studying is
because in the Pinocchio movie,
Jimminy Cricket is an Avatar of Christ
essentially.
But it's very strange because he's a
bug.
That's the first thing that's kind of
weird because Jimminy cricket is
southern US slang for Jesus Christ among
other things.
But these things get aggregated in,
in great mythic dramas like that.
And that's a great mythic drama.
But you know,
one of the things that really makes
jimminy cricket different from Christ,
apart from the fact that Christ wasn't a
cricket is that created the cricket
learns as he progresses,
right?
Even though he's the conscience.
And so you'd think that he would be the
infallible guide.
That isn't how the movie makers set it
up.
And that's so cool is that he's just as
muddle headed as Pinocchio at the
beginning and he's a bit arrogant,
puffed up to.
And so it took me a long time to think
that through.
And then I realized that,
well,
you have the voice of the voice of
culture in you.
You have the voice of culture within
you,
but it's old and dead and out of date
and it's not fully articulated.
An updated.
And then what happens is that if you
enter into a dialogue with it and you
hammer yourself against the world,
then you get hammered into shape and so
does your conscience.
And so you both become elevated and so
well.
So anyways,
I think that's,
that's ridiculously cool because it
means that your conscience,
you don't have an infallible guide,
but you have something within you that
you could build into an infallible guide
if you cooperated with it and fed it so
well.
So I think that's very interesting.
So that being said,
the picture that I have in my mind of
the cultivation of virtue in general,
it's kind of like taking a,
a block of wood and trying to carve out
a sphere out of it.
It'll never be perfectly round.
But the more you carve,
right?
The rounder and Roderick,
that successive approximation.
Yeah.
Well one of it's also like,
um,
what do you call compound interest?
This is one of the things that's also,
and I think this puts you on the to
those who more shall be given part of
the curve.
It's like,
you know,
you don't have to improve yourself very
much each week to really improve
yourself on a ridiculous amount in a
year.
You know,
so you could make,
you could,
you could vow to make your day one 100th
of a percent better than the day before,
and that would do the trick if you were,
if you were constant about that,
that would do the trick.
So that,
that's the success of approximation is
you don't want to underestimate the
utility of incremental progress.
Man,
it's really kids deadly powerful.
So,
so let's say you get to the,
you know,
the,
the higher ends of the curve,
right?
You're like a pretty virtuous person.
Let's say you even become a sage or
something of the sort,
and I mean one,
should you doubt your conscience,
like what are the things that we should
watch out for even when we got some.
Great.
Well that's okay just to get out of the
way,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know how much this relates.
Well,
it does relate,
but psychopaths,
for example,
the entire idea that they lack a
conscience and that's why,
right?
That's what psychopathy is.
Whether or not you agree with that
definition,
right?
But there's an issue of conscience,
again,
a play with psychopathy.
How can we the first question,
doubt ourselves in a way that's
warranted,
right?
Regardless of how virtuous we've become.
And can you treat a psychopath?
Could they cultivate a conscience?
Okay,
so let's,
we'll start with the first one.
Part of the reason that,
that I believe that freedom of speech is
the canonical,
right?
That's an obligation,
More importantly,
even obligation is that that's how you
figure out if you're wrong,
you know,
because.
So I sit home and I think,
and I think,
and I think let's say,
but I'm like,
who am I to think?
There's so many things.
I don't know that it's just,
there's the one I know compared to what
I don't know is so minuscule that it's a
preposterous act just to say something.
Okay.
So,
so no matter how much I sit at home and
think I'm not going to fix that,
I'm going to be fun.
And then I have biases,
but my temperament and I have biases
because of my malevolence and I have
biases because of my gender,
my sex,
let's say,
since we're not so fond of that word.
So Eva,
no matter how much I sit home and think
I'm still going to be wrong and
malevolent,
so then whenever I have to do is I have
to talk to some other people and I have
to say this is what I think,
and it's going to be ugly,
you know,
because what the hell do I know?
But then if I listen,
people will tell me why I'm wrong and
lots of people have been telling me why
I'm wrong like a lot and it's hard,
you know,
it's hard,
but it's.
But I've learned something from it like
I had this
revelation,
let's say about being yelled at by your
father.
Now I know that you can be yelled at too
much by your father,
but it's like you're wrong man.
And so someone's yelling at you and
maybe they're only 10 percent right?
But if you shut the hell up and listen,
then you can figure out where you're
wrong.
And then maybe you can be thankful for
that.
And then maybe if you shut up and
listened,
your father would quit yelling at you.
You know,
because he's wrong too.
What the hell does he know?
He knows how to yell at you and tell you
how you're wrong,
and he's throwing things out.
You add you that are probably not true,
but some of it's true and you know,
if someone can tell you why you're
wrong,
they've given you a great gift because
then you don't have to be wrong anymore.
And you might think,
well who cares if you're wrong,
but you know there's a line in the new
testament too,
is if the blind lead the blind,
won't they fall in?
Won't they fall into a ditch?
And the answer to that question by the
way,
is yes,
they will.
And so the reason that you want to think
is because thinking is how you.
It like when you think you created a
fictional world that's,
that's an analog of the world.
And then you make an Avatar of yourself
to act in that world.
And then if the Avatar dies,
you don't act out those actions.
Right?
Well,
so if you think properly,
then you don't have to suffer and die.
And so if you can say what you think and
people can tell you why you're wrong and
you know to say what you think under
extreme circumstances means that you're
going to say things that no one wants to
hear because those are the things you
don't know about.
Those are the things that are
conflictual and difficult it,
those are going to be hard
conversations,
man.
And you're going to be wrong about them
a lot.
If you don't get to stumble forward with
your stupidity,
then you can't be corrected.
And so,
so there is no distinction between free
speech and thinking and there's no
distinction between thinking and
thriving.
And so those who want to inhibit free
speech do not wish for people to thrive.
And I believe that.
So
thinking does not happen inside your
head.
That's the only the beginnings of
thinking.
And it's this,
that we're doing here that's thinking,
you know,
so we have to protect that.
Psychopaths,
I don't,
I say this,
I hope non naively
also having dealt with psychopaths in my
clinical practice and I would say now
and then in my life,
I don't believe in psychopaths.
I don't believe that we know enough to
say there are people born without,
um,
I don't think the psychometric
measurement of psychopathy is everything
that it should be.
I've been trying to model it in the big
five domain.
I think now it's complicated because.
So I would say a psychopath,
a classic psychopath is likely
extroverted,
especially assertive,
disagreeable and unconscientious and
maybe extremely low in neuroticism,
so you can't frighten them.
But.
So that's a rare combination because
it's extreme on many traits,
right?
But that,
I don't believe that that means that
someone with that personality
configuration is doomed from birth to a
pathological existence because there's
things about psychopathy that,
that the,
that the classifiers,
those who claim like clinically that the
psychopath is born in some sense can't
explain.
It's like,
well,
what about the cruelty?
It seems to be a motive there,
you know,
with are passionless and they lack,
they lack emotion.
Well,
why are they cruel then for
entertainment?
Well,
but then you have to explain the
entertainment motivation.
Like there's a failure in some sense
with the classic psychopathy theorists
to come to grips with the problem of
malevolence.
It's skirted over and you can't do that
if you're talking about psychopathy,
it's like malevolence is the bloody
issue here,
and so
the other issue with this psychopath is
that he's irredeemable,
right?
That's the idea.
I don't think we know enough to make
such claims now and that doesn't.
I know the psychopathy literature quite
well and I have great respect for their
primary research is in the field.
I want to make that perfectly clear,
but we're talking at a different.
We're talking,
we're approaching the problem from a
different level of analysis here.
Something like a spiritual level of
analysis and I don't think that there's
an easy easy translation from the
descriptive psychometric psychiatric
approach to the spiritual level.
They don't match and I'm more likely to
say let's not assume the soul is doomed
from birth.
Right.
And I'm loath to think that there are
people born irredeemable.
Although I do think there are
irredeemable.
People knew that the death penalty
issues.
Interesting in that regard.
You know,
because I've read a lot about really
terrible people and I've also read a lot
about what really terrible people said
about themselves and many of them wished
for the death penalty and so it's
absolutely clear that there are things
that you can do that deserved the death
penalty,
but that doesn't mean that the state
should have the right to impose it.
That's a different question.
So yeah,
thank you.
In the previous lecture,
you mentioned the 2008 economic crisis
and one of the very interesting themes
that's emerged at many levels be at
universities or economic policy is this
perceived culture war,
specifically the idea of Mark's versus
mill and you've criticized postmodern
and neo Marxist thought very frequently.
One interesting critic of,
uh,
policies of the EU,
specifically ECB,
ECB,
and IMF during the Greek debt crisis was
Yanis Varoufakis,
the former Greek finance minister and
his criticism of mill was the,
was mills alleged contempt for the
population and verify has comments on
the type of capitalism that results in
too big to fail.
He described themselves as an erratic
Marxist.
To me personally is an example of
someone whose position on the
philosophical moring of policy is
interesting to compare and contrast with
yours.
He's certainly not your typical Marxist,
so postmodernist,
even though I'm not really sure what
that means,
but if you look at his work during the
Greek debt crisis and his current work
with [inaudible],
he seems to be well reasoned,
well positioned and and articulate.
Now I wanted to know if you had an
opinion on that type of criticism of
mill or is taking of a position as an
erratic Marxist.
Okay.
I would say I would say no to the
specifics of the question.
I don't think that I have that detailed
expertise in order to answer the
question at the level of analysis that
you were.
You formulated it,
but I.
I have something to say that's more
general about the set of phenomena that
you described.
There is no doubt that distribution is a
major problem that capitalism contends
with imperfectly at best and the
distribution problem is the prieto
distribution problem right in,
and something that marks commented on,
which mostly in the monetary sphere is
that money tends to accumulate in the
hands of very few people.
It's like there's no doubt about that.
Now,
as we've discussed before,
the people in whom hands the money
accumulates do turnover more than people
think,
especially in,
in,
in countries that are functioning
reasonably well.
And it's really important that that
happens.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But that doesn't,
that doesn't solve the problem of the
fact that produced goods gravitate
towards an extreme minority.
Now there are also produced often by
extreme minority,
which is also a problem.
Um,
I would say then that the idea that
capitalism is more prone to that
distribution problem than any other
system,
I don't believe that to have been
demonstrated at all.
And I think that capitalism is actually
pretty good at self destruction except
when that's interfered with.
And I think that's particularly the case
in the United States were generally the
policy has been,
if you're an idol with feet of clay,
no matter how big you are,
you get to fail now.
That's been compromised severely in the
last 20 years and we're probably going
to pay for that.
I think they really paid for that in
Japan,
right?
Where there was every attempt to prop
out the gods that should have died.
So.
So fair enough for the critique of
capitalism.
That's not the issue.
The issue is do you have a better idea?
And if the idea is well,
we could kind of do it,
mark suggested,
then you don't get to have that position
and claim.
What should I say?
I haven't seen any evidence that systems
predicated on that set of axioms have
done anything but more harm than good.
And when will you be announcing the
monthly extension to this?
The series?
As soon as I find out whether or not I
can rent this theater in the fall.
Yeah,
thank you.
We'll see you next week.